[Musique]
le
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro des matins du
sénat ce matin je vous propose de
revivre l'audition d'alexandre benalla
hier devant la commission d' enquête du
sénat l'ancien chargé de mission de
l'elysée est mise en examen par la
justice pour avoir utilisé ces
passeports diplomatiques après son
licenciement
mais les sénateurs se sont intéressés au
rôle de l'elysée dans cette affaire afin
de pointer certains dysfonctionnements
ils ont aussi voulu savoir si alexandre
benalla leur avait menti lors de sa
première audition en septembre en
assurant qu'à ce moment
ces passeports diplomatiques se trouvait
bien à l'elysée vous allez voir
alexander benalla a donné sa version des
faits aux sénateurs en expliquant
notamment qu'un membre de l'elysée lui
avait restitué ces passeports
diplomatiques en octobre je vous laisse
écouter cette audition je souhaitais
avant tout en propos liminaire remettre
l'ensemble de cette affaire dite affaire
benalla dans le contexte ce qui est le
sien cette affaire elle intervient au
moment des évènements dits du 1er mai de
la place de la contrescarpe dont on l'a
dit un certain nombre de choses mais
surtout on est en train de le constater
maintenant avec le temps qui passe à un
certain nombre de contre-vérités un
certain nombre d'approximations à la
fois relié par la presse mais aussi par
un certain nombre de responsables
politiques
on m'a d'abord présenté comme le tabac
soeur des gentils manifestants
d'autres ont employé le mot opposants
politiques et d'autre les mangeurs de
crêpes comme ils se sont même présentés
en tronquant la réalité d'une situation
qui était pour le moins assez tendu et
on est en train de le découvrir depuis
plusieurs semaines assez confuse j'ai
dès le début lors de différentes
interventions médiatiques qui ont été
les miennes à la fois au jt de 20 heures
de tf1
également dans le journal du dimanche et
dans le journal le monde je suis revenu
sur cette situation du 1er mai où j'ai
expliqué que les personnes qui étaient
en face de moi n'étaient pas des gentils
manifestants mais des lanceurs de
bouteilles en verre sur des policiers ce
qui a été difficile à admettre pour un
certain nombre de journalistes pour un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques
mais ce qui s'est conclue être la
réalité dès lors que les vidéos sont
sorties dans les médias
après quelques semaines où on les a
quand même gardé sous le coude où on
voit ces deux personnes en train de
jeter des bouteilles en verre et
d'agresser littéralement les policiers
aujourd'hui ces deux personnes je
reviens qu'on a présenté comme des
gentils manifestants sont convoqués par
la justice pour répondre de faits de
violences sur dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
alors il ya également tout un contexte
autour de ça qui était de savoir est ce
que j'avais à agir pas agir ça c'est pas
à moi de vous le dire aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le sujet de cette audition
j'ai bien compris ce sera à la justice
de déterminer si ce que j'ai fait le 1er
mai en contribuant à l'appréhension de
deux délinquants
tout comme hd qualifie comme ça deux
lanceurs de bouteilles sur des policiers
est ce que j'avais à le faire ou pas à
le faire j'ai pensé bien faire en vertu
d'un article s'appelle l'article 73 du
code de procédure pénale qui indique que
n'importe quel citoyen est autorisé à
appréhender l'auteur d'un crime ou d'un
délit flagrant et en l'occurrence le jet
d'une bouteille en verre sur des
policiers ça s'appelle un délit ce sont
des violences volontaires sur
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
à l'issue de ces pseudo révélation n'a
un grand quotidien du soir il ya eu je
le voulais déjà dit la dernière fois un
déferlement médiatique
un déchaînement politique un lâchage en
règle dont j'ai fait l'objet et je
continue d'ailleurs à faire l'objet
depuis six mois avec la construction
d'un personnage d'un individu comme l'a
pu l'appeler quelqu'un qui est venu
devant vous très récemment
alors que je constate et le mois de
septembre qui le tarissait pas d'éloges
me concernant mais vise apparemment là
sa vision a changé de manière assez
rapide
parce qu'en six mois on a réussi à
construire et à faire de moi un
personnage qu'on dise sulfureux
diabolique
infréquentable enfin ce sont tous les
qualificatifs qui sont employés à mon
encontre et je pense de manière très
modeste avoir contribué à la
construction de ce personnage de par des
propos que j'ai pu tenir qui ont été
situés hors de leur contexte mais aussi
de par parfois mon attitude quitté qui a
peut-être été jugée décalé et je je je
le conçois que j'ai pu donner une
mauvaise image de moi mais je tenais
devant vous monsieur le président à
remettre dans le contexte cette pseudo
affaire benalla où on a bien vu le
cheminement la construction
médiatico-politique qui n'avaient qu'un
seul but atteindre le président de la
république
je pense que ça a marché et j'espère que
ça va se terminer assez rapidement pour
mon pays et pour la réussite que je
souhaite au président de la république
en l'espace de six mois
les choses ont bien changé elles ont
évolué plutôt négativement en ce qui me
concerne et je dois vous le dire et le
reconnaître derrière la carapace il ya
un homme sa femme son fils qui avait un
mois et demi au moment du déclenchement
de de cette affaire une situation
professionnelle et personnelle assez
troublée qui ont fait que j'ai commis un
certain nombre d'erreurs des erreurs que
j'ai reconnu volontiers auprès de mes
proches près de mon entourage et que je
reconnais publiquement devant vous et je
les fais également devant la justice ses
erreurs elles n'ont pu l'être de par des
rencontres de par des échanges avec
certaines personnes encore une fois
qualifié de sulfureuses et je tiens à
vous le dire je rencontre qui je veux
quand je veux et dans le cadre que je
veux en fixant des limites morales que
je garderai pour moi mais je n'accepte
pas
le personnage qui a été construit autour
de moi et qu'il ne reflète pas la
réalité de ce que je suis qui je suis et
ce que j'ai fait lorsque j'étais à la
présidence de la république
je venais aussi rappelé devant vous que
j'ai été recrutés sur la base de mes
compétences qui n'ont jamais été depuis
le début de vos auditions remise en
cause par qui que ce soit par qui que ce
soit je n'ai pas débarquer à l'elysée
par effraction j'ai participé à une
campagne électorale où j'ai exercé mes
compétences avec mes qualités et mes
défauts et ont mis à recruter sur la
seule base de mes compétences et de mon
savoir faire et je demande juste un peu
d'indulgence me concernant
de par le traitement médiatique
politique qui est le mien et je pense
que la justice qui fait son travail
sereinement a toute sa place dans notre
pays pour faire la lumière sur tout ce
qui m'a été reproché depuis le début de
cette affaire
j'ai entendu un certain nombre
d'approximations de mensonges et de
contrevérités dans les précédents
témoignages des gens que vous avez pu
auditionner
j'ai un immense respect pour les
fonctions qu'ils occupent et aujourd'hui
je ne vous parlerai pas de ce que je
pense des hommes dans la droite ligne de
ce que je vous ai dit la dernière fois
monsieur le président bas
je suis venue devant vous le 19
septembre j'ai fait un certain nombre de
déclarations jaurès cohérent dans mon
propos j'ai pu entendre ici ou là qu'il
n'avait pas été suffisamment clair sur
certains points que j'avais fait de
l'enfumage ça aujourd'hui je suis
présente devant vous pour répondre à
toutes les interrogations auxquelles
vous avez jugé peut-être que j'avais été
vague tout ce que j'ai pu entendre à la
sortie de cette audition du 19 septembre
je veux juste vous confirmer mon propos
madame la sénatrice quand vous m'avez
posé la question de savoir est ce que
vous avez rendu vos passeports
diplomatiques je me souviens place des
termes exacts de votre question mais je
me rappelle de ma réponse le 19
septembre lorsque j'étais présent devant
vous sous serment et que j'ai répondu à
l'ensemble des questions qui m'ont été
posées
je vous ai dit ils doivent être dans mon
bureau à l'elysée et ils ont dû les
restituer suisse may phrasé est complète
je vous réaffirme solennellement sous
serment encore une fois que le 19
septembre mais passeport était à
l'elysée patrick strzoda vous a affirmé
que ces passeports avaient été utilisées
entre le 1er et le 7 août
ce que je ne dénie pas c'est la réalité
je les ai restituer à la demande de la
présidence de la république et du
ministère des affaires étrangères qui
m'a adressé deux courriers ainsi qu'un
email que j'ai reçu de la part du
général bio-farina le 30 juillet j'ai
restituer mais passeport l'été de mon
bureau
le badge d'accès à l'elysée et j'ai
récupéré un certain nombre d'autres
affaires comme un siège auto et un
chéquier une perte de clés également et
1 alors que je désire restituer dans le
courant du mois d'août 2010 800 être
précis sur les dates pour l'instant
aucune information judiciaire est en
cours et elle viendra confirmer mon
propos et ses passeports ont été rendus
à nouveau alors que j'avais été contacté
par un membre de l'elysée un personnel
salarié de l'elysée début octobre 2018
ils m'ont été restitués comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure avec un certain
nombre d'éléments personnels un chéquier
une paire de clés
dans des conditions qui sont celles
qu'elles ont été je tiens juste à vous
dire que j'ai constaté que ces
passeports et on m'a fait savoir que ces
passeports n'étaient pas désactivé sinon
je n'aurais pas voyagé avec ses
passeports et je reconnais là une faute
de ma part un manque de discernement
peut-être une erreur sans doute gelé
reconnu devant la justice et je la
reconnais devant vous mais je ne pense
pas que ça mérite les proportions que
tout ça a pris depuis le début de cette
affaire
donc je vous le réaffirme solennellement
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
co-rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je ne vous ai pas menti le 19 septembre
lorsque je vous ai dit que mes passeport
était à l'elysée et encore une fois je
fais confiance à la justice qui
travaillent dans la sphère du 1er mai
qui fait émerger un certain nombre de
vérités sur des mensonges des rumeurs
des contrevérités qui ont été
développées ici ou là et donc elle fera
la même chose sur cette affaire des
passeports diplomatiques
voilà ce que j'avais à vous dire
monsieur le président merci monsieur
benalla j'avais donné la parole au
président jean pierre sueur
co-rapporteur merci monsieur le
président monsieur benalla je voulais
d'abord peux vous dire que alors que
nous étions interrogés encore très
récemment philippe bas muriel jourda et
moi même avons toujours maintenu la même
position
nous sommes ici rassemblés pour trouver
la vérité pour trouver les
dysfonctionnements qui ont eu lieu pour
mettre à jour les dysfonctionnements en
chercher les causes et ensuite nous
verrons un rapport dans lequel nous
dirons ce que nous aurons à dire mais
nous respectons nous mêmes le
contradictoire c'est-à-dire que nous
auditionnons toutes les personnes que
nous avons décidé d'auditionner
et pour le moment nous en sommes là et
nous n'allons pas au delà de cet acte
qui est conforme à notre mission de
parlementaires
je voulais vous poser une première
question nous allons alterner les
questions par rapport à eux à votre
activité
quand vous étiez à l'elysée pouvez vous
confirmer véritablement que vous n'avez
été en lien avec aucune société privée
liée à des activités de sécurité de
défense ou d'autres domaines pendant que
vous exerciez vos fonctions à l'elysée
super nanas merci pour votre question
bien sûr qu'on va porter sur je vais
réaffirmer solennellement devant vous
que je n'avais aucun lien d'ordre
professionnel avec une société de
sécurité ou de défense comme vous me
posez la question mais pour être très
clair tout le monde sait ici je suis
issu du milieu de la sécurité la
protection des personnes que j'ai
travaillé dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises auparavant et donc que je
me suis créé des liens d'amitié avec un
certain nombre de personnes dans divers
domaines d'ailleurs et pas seulement la
sécurité la protection physique des
personnes et que je continue encore
aujourd'hui parce que les vrais amis
restent malgré ce déchaînement à
entretenir des liens d'amitié avec un
certain nombre de personnes mais je
répète devant vous je n'ai vu aucun lien
professionnel avec des sociétés de
sécurité ou de défense lorsque j'ai
coupé mes fonctions à l'elysée de
libération a publié une déclaration de
vous entre guillemets selon laquelle que
vous auriez organisée je cite entre
guillemets deux ou trois rendez-vous à
l'elysée pendant vos fonctions avec
monsieur vincent mickeler confirmez vous
cela
et de quoi il s'agissait
thil je dément ces propos et devant vous
aujourd'hui pour faire votre travail
sérieusement je ne commenterai pas les
articles de presse dans lequel il ya eu
absolument tout et son contraire et
surtout beaucoup de contre-vérités qui
ont été écrites
je n'ai jamais prononcé ces propos à
libération je vous donne acte de votre
réponse je voulais vous demander si vous
connaissiez monsieur iskander makhmoudov
je ne connais pas cette personne nous à
part à travers la presse je ne les ai
jamais rencontrés
e étiez vous informer de la coupole
collaboration de monsieur kraz avec
monsieur à tout mode off alors je sais
que monsieur kraz a eu des activités
professionnelles qu'il a créé une
entreprise
j'étais au courant de ces affaires oui
c'est un ami je vais pas le cacher
devant vous aujourd'hui
tout ce que je peux vous affirmer
aujourd'hui c'est que je n'ai jamais
contribué à une quelconque négociation
conclusion est que je n'ai jamais été
intéressé au moindre contrat comme ce
cra a pu passer avec qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs
et comment cette personne avez vous eu
des contacts avec une personne
particulièrement proches de monsieur
makhmoudov ce qui justifierait que vous
ne l'ayez pas vu personnellement
alors il pour répond encore très
clairement et précisément je connais un
certain nombre de personnes on l'a tous
vu dans les articles de presse qui dit
parfois des vérités parfois des
mensonges mais je connais beaucoup de
gens j'en ai rencontré de par mes
anciens camarades par d'anciennes
fonctions par d'anciens emplois et donc
on est un tout petit milieu et on se
connaît absolument tout donc je connais
un certain nombre de gens soient dans
l'entourage de vincent kraz dans
l'entourage de la société si vous voulez
venir là dessus de velours parce que
j'ai travaillé pour eux et voilà je
perds dire le contraire mais connaître
des gens c'est ce que vous pouvez
aujourd'hui me reprocher mais je connais
beaucoup de gens oui je le connais
beaucoup de gens
s'est-il fait que après avoir quitter
vos fonctions vous ayez été employé
pendant un mois pour un salaire qui est
connu par une société qui s'est créée
pour le besoin de la cause me
semble-t-il dont l'actionnariat est
assez léger qui est dirigé par une
personne que vous devez connaître et
quelle a été votre activité dans le
cadre de cette société une activité
éphémère pour une société qui venait de
naître
monsieur le sénateur je vais répondre à
cette question même si je suis pas
obligé de vous y répondre parce que elle
c'est une activité professionnelle que
j'ai exercé à l'issue de mes activités à
l'elysée je vous avais dit quand vous
m'aviez interrogé la première fois que
j'étais à pôle emploi
j'ai essayé de quitter pôle emploi le
plus rapidement possible et j'essaye de
refaire ma vie professionnelle et
personnelle par mes propres moyens avec
certaines personnes qui me veulent du
bien et je les en remercie
et aujourd'hui je suis profondément
choquée qu'ils soient jetés en pâture
alors ce sont des entrepreneurs sérieux
qui passent des contrats et quand une
entreprise passe un contrat moi ça me
fait plaisir qui emploie des gens encore
une fois sur la base de leurs
compétences que ces gens là où tout se
retrouve avec le nom de leur société
leur prénom leur nom le passé ce qu'ils
ont fait avant et s'est jetée en pâture
comme ça c'est irresponsable
irresponsable de la part des médias qui
en fait depuis six mois
moeurs elle harcèle mes proches et dont
le seul intérêt de connaître la couleur
des chaussettes que je mets le mercredi
ou le jeudi
il faut juste un moment me laisser
tranquille je travaille
j'essaie de gagner ma vie par moi même
ne pas être à la charge de la société et
cette personne c'est un ami à moi que
j'ai rencontrée je vous le dis encore
une fois c'est un petit milieu
on se connaît depuis plus de cinq ans
avec la personne que vous évoquez je
crois que monsieur crasse le connaît
aussi très bien voilà il ya des concours
de circonstances qui parfois on va
chercher la petite bête mais aujourd'hui
je
peux juste vous affirmer que c'est un
ami qui m'a employé dans une mission qui
restera confidentiel je suis désolé me
permets de vous demander la nature de
l'activité qui a été la vôtre
à ce titre en raison du fait que lorsque
l'on a servi dans un service public
grans l'elysée ce que l'on fait après
n'est pas indifférent surtout si on a
exercé des missions liées aux missions
de sécurité lorsque l'on était à
l'elysée vous savez qu'il ya une
commission de déontologie et c'est donc
je vous le demande avec insistance
qu'elle a été la nature de votre travail
durant un mois au sein de cette société
pour des raisons de confidentialité
évidentes et du fait que ça ne concerne
pas aujourd'hui votre mission
d'information qui allait pouvoir d'une
commission denquête je ne répondrai pas
à cette question monsieur le sénateur
jeu bénin et c'est nous qui décidons si
nos propres questions sont dans notre
mandat ou pas ce n'est pas à vous de le
faire je vais vous préciser les choses
pour que vous les entendiez clairement
la sanction de licenciement pour faute
qui vous a été infligée comporte un
certain nombre de l'obligation pour vous
si cette sanction est réelle elle doit
tenait jusqu'au bout c'est la raison
pour laquelle comme vous le savez vous
deviez rendre tout ce qui était les
instruments de votre fonction et ses
attributs comme les passeports
diplomatiques d'une ligne vous ne
l'ignorez pas mais c'est aussi pour
laquelle si vous permettez
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle vous
devez respecter ayant servi au plus haut
niveau de l'état à la présidence de la
république même si vous n'étiez pas un
des principaux collaborateurs du chef de
l'état vous devez respecter l'obligation
de soumettre à la commission de
déontologie de la fonction
public les nouvelles activités que vous
pouvez avoir
tout ceci a du sens le droit ne s'est
pas simplement des règles compose pour
embêter les gens pourquoi ces règles
existent c'est pour s'assurer d'une
certaine façon que rétrospectivement la
personne qui prend une activité dans le
secteur privé après avoir servi l'état
ne peut pas se trouver en situation de
conflit d'intérêts et c'est aussi pour
vérifier qu'à l'avenir les fonctions que
cette personne va exercer pour le compte
d'une entreprise respectable comme vous
l'avez dit par hypothèse seront des
fonctions qui ne mettront pas en cause
des informations acquises dans
l'exercice de la fonction de service
public qu'on a eu
si bien que notre commission d' enquête
s'intéresse tout à fait légitimement au
rheu et monsieur sûr je crois est tout à
fait dans son rôle en vous posant ses
questions aux activités que vous pouvez
avoir et aux conditions dans lesquelles
vous exercer ses activités c'est à dire
que vous voyez c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de règles en france elles ne
sont pas toutes inutile et dépourvue de
sens celle là beaucoup de sens en
réalité donc je reformule la question de
jean-pierre sueur différemment avant de
prendre une activité dans une entreprise
savez-vous petit saisi la commission de
déontologie et petit petit b petit 2
avez vous informé la présidence de la
république que vous repreniez comme
c'est nécessaire pour vous même et pour
votre famille une activité
professionnelle et la nature de cette
activité professionnelle ça c'est
extrêmement important c'est le respect
des dispositions du décret du 27 janvier
je vous remercie pour votre intervention
monsieur le président sur en effet vous
avez raison c'est très important
et d'ailleurs c'est tellement important
que j'ai reçu le courrier de monsieur
strzoda m'indiquant que j'avais à saisir
la commission de déontologie de la
fonction publique deux jours avant qu'il
soit auditionné par vos soins à sa
dernière audition
c'est tellement important qu'il serait
intéressant aussi de savoir combien de
personnes quittant l'elysée depuis
plusieurs mandats il faudrait
s'intéresser aux derniers mandats ont
saisi cette commission de déontologie
pour avoir des activités
professionnelles et pour créer leur
entreprise ça je pense que c'est un
travail et qui pourrait être assez
intéressant
et pourquoi on me demande à moi trois
jours avant de venir dans une commission
denquête de saisir cette confiance qui
m'avait ce que ce dont je n'avais pas
été informé mais qui était mentionné
dans mon contrat de travail c'est tout à
fait exact
je ne l'ait pas fait c'est une erreur de
ma part je la reconnais mais il serait
intéressant de s'intéresser savoir
combien de personnes en sortant de
l'elysée saisissent la commission de
déontologie de la fonction publique
mais monsieur benalla vous n'avez pas
toujours by ministre hâtives
vous savez bien qu'il faut respecter d
un certain nombre de règles et vous
venez de rappeler que c'était dans votre
contrat de travail
c'est pas très compliqué à faire je
pense que ça a été la situation à
l'issue de mes fonctions à l'elysée a
été un peu compliqué et je n'ai pas été
orientés vers cette commission de
déontologie
j'aurais dû en effet le 1er août
reprendre mon contrat de travail et
relire chaque paraphe et voir que je
devais saisir cette commission de
déontologie je ne l'ait pas fait c'est
en effet c'est une erreur de ma part
mais j'avais d'autres priorités comme
celle de mettre à l'abri et ma femme et
mon fils de retrouver un appartement un
travail ouais c'est des situations en
fait à un tout petit peu compliqué ce
qu'il se passe
suivez nous ne sommes pas là pour vous
faire l'amour mais vous pourrez essayer
d'avoir des informations qui nous
permettent d'établir la vérité mais
c'est certain que quand on respecte les
règles on est mieux protégé alors je
voudrais savoir si depuis lors vous avez
effectivement saisi la commission de
déontologie
non je n'ai pas saisi la commission de
déontologie et mon avocate est en train
de s'en occuper
je vous remercie madame jourdain merci
monsieur le président j'ai quelques
questions à monsieur benalla sur le port
d'armes
le préfet de police de paris vous a
délivré le 13 octobre 2017 outre un
permis de port d'armes une autorisation
d'acquisition et de détention d'une arme
de catégorie b uniquement valable pour
la durée de vos fonctions à la
présidence de la république
selon les informations nous avons à vous
bénéficiez déjà depuis le mois de
novembre 2016 d'une autorisation de
détention d'armes de cette même
catégorie au motif que vous pratiquez le
tir sportif
avez-vous acquis une nouvelle arme au
titre de l'autorisation d'acquisition et
détention délivré par le préfet de
police le 13 octobre 2017
et si oui cette arme at elle été acquise
par vous même à titre privé ou par
l'elysée alors je répondrais de manière
très succincte parce qu'il ya une
information judiciaire en cours là
dessus sur l'histoire des armes du
fameux selphy je peux juste vous dire
que larmes qui a été acquise dans le
cadre de cette autorisation l'a été par
moi même
madame jourdain dans la mesure où
l'autorisation dont vous bénéficiez
était liée à vos fonctions à l'elysée
avait vous restituer cette arme
postérieurement sept armes ont été
saisies armes pardon en suivant toutes
les armes que je détenais de manière
légale ont été saisis par la justice
dans le cadre de l'information
judiciaire qui est en cours
merci de cette réponse madame jourda
d'autres questions allez-y allez-y
allez-y padum jours gras sur sur les
soupes la question des sarts dont
monsieur urbain
je crois que madame jourdain vous voulez
poser une question je vous redonne la
parole après une question cette fois-ci
monsieur menace sur le téléphone
théorème qui permettent aux
collaborateurs situés au plus haut
niveau de l'état de passer des
communications chiffrées
selon les informations qui nous ont été
données par monsieur strzoda directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
la présidence dispose de trente combiné
vous même vous disposiez d'un s'est
combiné alors à quelle fin disposez vous
d'un téléphone théorème dans le cadre de
vos fonctions à l'elysée
à quelles fins utilisiez vous pour
préparer des déplacements pour
communiquer avec le président ben ali
alors pour répondre à cette question
le théorème en effet est un outil qui
est mis à disposition d'un certain
nombre de collaborateurs du président de
la république et d'autres
administrations qui permet d'avoir un
certain nombre de conversations
téléphoniques de manière sécurisée
quand j'étais collaborateurs du
président de la république dans les
fonctions qui étaient les miennes j'ai
trés j'étais excusez moi très soucieux
des procédures et de la sécurité des
communications je pouvais avoir
il m'a été attribué à un théorème dans
le cadre des missions que je vous ai
exposé lors de la première audition
juste certains n'ont pas jugé utile d'en
avoir un préférant passer par des
messagerie crypté bien connu télégramme
whatsapp c'est à moi j'ai respecté les
procédures c'est à dire que lorsqu'on a
des discussions à voir avec des prêts
faits avec les autorités se veut la
police la gendarmerie ou d'autres
personnes qui ont leurs fonctions à
l'elysée
j'utilisais le théorème voilà qui est un
outil qui a été achetée plutôt qu'ils
soient dans un carton je l'utilisé
mais monsieur benalla ça veut dire que
le chef de cabinet du président de la
république ne jugeait pas utile pour ses
propres communications avec les mêmes
correspondante d'utiliser un tel
appareil et c'est donc vous qui à la
chefferie de cabinet l'utilisiez vous
seul mais de votre propre initiative en
quelque sorte vous vous avez pensé que
c'était utile alors que d'autres
pensaient que c'était inutile
je pense que vous avez parfaitement
résumé la situation de sur le président
je vous remercie monsieur sueur pardon
cette fois madame jourda qui tout allait
résister à engager un nouveau
questionnaire questionnement demande a
continué sur le même sujet oui j'aurais
bien voulu doit-on saisir de vos propos
monsieur vénéra que ce téléphone vous
l'aviez demandé et qu'il nous ait qui ne
vous avait pas été attribués d'office
alors en fait nous avons des postes
fixes sécurisé dans chacun de nos
bureaux à la chefferie de cabinet les
pokes les postes mobiles ne sont pas
attribuées de manière automatique alors
même que nos fonds les fonctions qui
sont les nôtres de par l'habilitation
etc emporte le fait qu'on peut demander
ce type de mobile après c'est en
fonction de l'usagé qu'on veut en faire
et du respect moi j'ai un respect des
procédures de sécurité et je les ai
utilisés aux fins qui pour lequel et fsr
téléphoner dans des conditions de
sécurité
axione d'autres ne l'ont pas jugé utile
s'est alors posé la question vous n'avez
pas tout à fait répondu à ma question
l'aviez vous demandez où vous at il été
attribuée d'office
alors il m'a été attribué
vous me confirmer que ce téléphone a été
restituée lors de votre licenciement et
le cas échéant la restitution vous at
elle été réclamés après votre
licenciement à quel moment et qu'elle
glisse jean savez-vous accompli pour que
ce cette restitution ait lieu pour
inscrire ma réponse dans le contexte
général que je vous ai exposé tout à
l'heure monsieur le président bah la
situation après le 1er août était un peu
confus je me concernant j'ai déménagé en
six mois plus de quatre fois avec un
certain nombre d'affaires dans des
cartons c'est une situation compliquée
je vais pas m'étaler là-dessus mais ce
téléphone ne m'a jamais été redemandé et
je n'avais pas connaissance
jusqu'au mois de décembre que je l'avais
encore en ma possession c'est à dire que
le dernier déménagement que j'ai fait le
20 novembre 2018 pour être tout à fait
précis avec vous j'ai ouvert des cartons
et lorsqu'on a commencé à me demander la
restitution d'un certain nombre d'effets
qui n'avait pas été rendue à l'elysée
la carte professionnelle le pin's et un
certain nombre d'autres documents et il
n'était pas mentionné le théorème est
donc j'ai demande fait avec ma femme un
inventaire complet des affaires qui
n'était pas encore déballés on à
déballer les cartons et on est tombé sur
le théorème est donc j'ai appelé mon
avocate qui a pris effet les démarches
auprès de monsieur strzoda pour savoir
comment on pouvait restituer ce
téléphone voilà et depuis il a été
restitué à l'elysée on aime jourda une
dernière question et je redonne la
parole à jean pierre sueur toujours sur
ce téléphone qui l usage à vous fait de
cet outil depuis votre licenciement
comme je vous ai dit il ya eu aucun
usage de ce téléphone ce que je n'avais
pas connaissance pendant les six mois
qui se sont écoulés avant que je fasse
un inventaire complet des affaires qui
étaient encore dans des cartons
que je l'avais encore en ma possession
voilà donc il n'a jamais été utilisé
depuis le mois de juillet 2018
je vous remercie jean pierre sueur sur
ce téléphone
l'elysée nous a affirmé vous avoir
demandé de le restituer le 4 octobre ce
qui est un peu loin par rapport à la
date de votre départ
mais vous ne l'avez pas restitué le 4
octobre bien qu'on voulait demander
alors contrairement à ce que vous
affirmez je sais pas qui a dit ça sur la
base de quoi il se met ce téléphone ne
m'a jamais été réclamée le 4 octobre
ils ont découvert apparemment lorsque
mon avocate a appelé pour leur dire
qu'on en était en possession que je
l'avais encore mais ça n'a jamais été
demandée par l'elysée le 4 octobre
en réalité le téléphone a été désactivé
le 4 octobre
ce tueur ce qui est étrange c'est une
remarque c'est que il est était que que
l'élysée donc alors que vous avez quitté
l'elysée le 31 juillet ne se soit rendu
compte de cette affaire que le 4 octobre
et ce en étant rendu compte si je
comprends ce que vous dites n'est pas
réagi auprès de vous pour vous demander
de le restituer c'est exactement ce que
vous dites je ne sais pas répondre à
votre question je pense que je parle
mieux placé pour les rapports pour port
d'armes permettez moi une question à
laquelle peut-être vous ne répondrai pas
mais il peut peut-être être utile pour
vous de répondre
il ya une perquisition vous en souvenez
cette perquisition n'a donné lieu à
aucune instance judiciaire n'est pas
couvert par la justice les conditions
dans lesquelles la perquisition a lieu
il a été question d'une armoire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur son contenu ou est-ce que vous ne
pouvez pas la perquisition elle s'est
fait sur instruction bien suivi un
magistrat donc par la justice et donc je
ne rentrerai pas dans des réponses ça
concerne l'information judiciaire et
l'instruction aussi la justice et des
questions à me poser là dessus elle me
les posera mais tout s'est fait dans un
cadre légal et une vraie perquisition à
mon domicile avec des vrais policiers
j'en suis le premier témoin tout a été
fait conformément à la loi
voilà bien merci dix danseurs par
rapport à eux au passeport
on a constaté que vous aviez une
certaine appétence pour les passeports
mais bon après tout chacun a ses
marottes de mai ce qui est quand même un
peu étrange c'est que s'agissant du
passeport diplomatique dont vous avez
demandé le renouvellement
premièrement vous avez demandé sur vous
de renouvellement au moment où après une
sanction qui vous étaient infligés qui a
été donc terminée vous avez été déchargé
de la mission de l'organisation des
voyages du président de la république
donc il peut sembler étrange quand vous
que vous demandiez un passeport
diplomatique au moment où n'avez vous
n'avez plus la mission qui justifierait
l'attribution le renouvellement du
passeport diplomatique
première question pourquoi avez vous
demandé ce passeport diplomatique alors
que vous n'aviez plus la fonction qui
aurait justifié que vous le demandiez
deuxièmement vous n'êtes pas passés par
le service du protocole de l'elysée
pourquoi puisque c'est la voie normale
vous avez obtenu ce passeport ce
renouvellement très rapidement auprès du
ministère des affaires étrangères qui en
a d'ailleurs informé monsieur le drian
nous l'a dit le service du protocole de
l'elysée qui après d'après nos
informations n'a pas réagi d'aucune
sorte
d'après nos informations donc je vous
pose ces questions pourquoi avez vous
demandé le renouvellement à cette époque
là pourquoi et pourquoi n'êtes vous pas
passer par le service du protocole alors
je suis désolé monsieur le sénateur mais
les conditions d'attribution de
détention et d'obtention
c'est que de restitution de ces
passeports concerne l'information
judiciaire en cours et j'aurai des
questions de deux juges d'instruction
qui sont saisis là dessus donc je ne
répondrai pas à ces questions devant
votre mission j'en suis désolé monsieur
ménard vous êtes obligé de répondre à
ces questions devant notre commission
elle concerne le fonctionnement de
l'état et non pas des fautes que vous
auriez pu commettre
et elles ne sont donc pas reliés à cette
information judiciaire sauf en avoir une
compréhension particulièrement extensif
je vous précise d'ailleurs mais je les
ai déjà dit plusieurs fois que nos
missions sont complémentaires
nous pouvons nous intéresser aux mêmes
faits mais pas pour le même objet la
justice veut s'intéresser à
l'utilisation que vous faites d'un
passeport diplomatique s'il ya une
infraction dans cette utilisation par
vous même
nous ne nous intéressons pas du tout ça
en revanche il est très important pour
nous de super notre mission
constitutionnelle sans en rien limitée
des capacités d'action de la justice nos
missions sont complémentaires et pas
concurrentes sur ce qui concerne les
procédures administratives qui ont eu
lieu nous voulons savoir comment cette
attribution a eu lieu elle n'est pas
poursuivie en tant que tel comme une
infraction non pas l'attribution de ce
passeport diplomatique alors que la
justice vous pose des questions
là-dessus
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
qu'elle le fasse mais nous vous posons
aussi des questions là dessus et vous
êtes obligés d'y répondre
j'ai bien entendu votre propos monsieur
prétention mais je suis désolé je vous
méprise embarras excusez moi
je ne pourrais pas répondre à cette
question parce que contrairement à ce
que vous affirmez la justice s'intéresse
aux conditions de délivrance et
d'obtention de l'ensemble des passeports
et pas seulement les passeports
diplomatiques dans le cadre d'une
information judiciaire qui est ouverte
sur cinq
motif d'infraction et pas seulement
lusage j'ai été mis en examen en effet
simplement sur l' usage abusive d'un
document donnant une fonction mais je
suis placé comme témoin assisté sur
quatre chefs d'inculpation
ce n'est pas tant un statut que
l'ouverture d'une information sur ces
cinq chefs d'inculpation qui m'empêche
de répondre à cette question sur les
dalles à la justice s'intéresse-t-elle
vraiment aux conditions dans lesquelles
vous avez obtenu le renouvellement de
votre passeport diplomatique au mois de
juin dernier
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai entendu le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république à utiliser l'article 40 du
pote 2 du code de procédure pénale non
pas pour l'attribution de ces passeports
diplomatiques mais pour la note en tête
du chef de cabinet du président de la
république par laquelle a été demandé le
renouvellement de votre passeport de
service qui n'a rien à voir avec le
renouvellement de votre passeport
diplomatique au mois de juin dernier
mais nous en resterons là je vous donne
acte de votre refus de répondre mais je
tiens à vous dire que votre
interprétation est erroné et que
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas opposé à une
commission d' enquête parlementaire
votre propre interprétation par rapport
à celle que nous faisons car c'est notre
rôle d'interpréter notre mandat est de
définir le champ des questions que nous
avons à vous poser et auxquelles vous
pourriez répondre j'ai précisé en
commençant cette audition
à quel point nous sommes de ce point de
vue très attentif à faire en sorte que
la séparation des pouvoirs soient
respectés et la conception que vous en
affirmé est de mon point de vue comme de
celui des rapporteurs abusive
alors j'ai bien entendu encore une fois
votre remarque monsieur le président bah
je suis assez inquiet de voir qu'une
première fois devant votre commission le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république
a évoqué que j'allais être convoqué dans
les toutes prochaines heures
ce qui pose quand même des questions sur
l'indépendance des institutions et
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train de
m'expliquer que vous n'avez pas
connaissance que dans le dossier la
justice s'intéresse à la condition
d'obtention et de délivrance de ces
passeports
je ne sais pas si vous avez eu accès au
dossier judiciaire vous même mais ça me
pose question quand même monsieur ne la
suivait n'a là je me fonde sur les chefs
sur les chefs d'un crédit nation et sur
les déclarations du parquet du même
monsieur le président sur wii je voulais
vous dire monsieur benalla qu' il n'y a
pas pas il n'y a pas eu moins de quatre
ministres et une certaine époque nous
ont rappelé qu'il était tout à fait
nécessaire que nous respections nos
prérogatives
donc nous ne pouvons qu insisté sur la
grande nécessité de respecter
l'indépendance de la justice comme la
justice se doit de respecter notre
indépendance mais surtout comme le
pouvoir exécutif se doit de respecter
l'indépendance du pouvoir législatif
mais monsieur benalla vous nous dites
que pour ces raisons liées à la justice
vous ne pouvez pas parler des passeports
mais vous voyez qu'il y a une petite
contradiction car dans votre déclaration
préalable
vous avez commencé par nous parler de
passeport attendez ce n'est pas fini ma
question
donc vous avez commencé par nous dire
que suite à la question de madame
eustache brinio notre collègue
vous avez apporté une réponse vous avez
apporté la réponse suivante que les
passeports quand vous avez quitté
l'elysée était resté dans votre bureau
tout à l'heure vous avez dit les
passeports sont restés à l'elysée c'est
une nuance qui a de l'importance
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
que les passeports sont restés dans
votre bureau à l'elysée alors comme très
précieux que j'en suis très précis je
vais d'abord rebondir sur le fait que je
n'ai pas évoqué alors toute autre
question portait sur les passeports
je n'ai pas excusez moi je n'ai pas
répondu à cette question parce qu'elle
s'inscrivait dans le cadre d'une
information judiciaire qui est ouverte
et que dans mon propos liminaire j'ai
évoqué ces passeports
je suis juste resté cohérent et des
propos qui ont été publics à travers un
certain nombre de communiqués à deux
mois et un de mon avocate
donc je n'avais pas vous dire je ne vais
pas je vous répète simplement les propos
qui ont été derrière il ya une quinzaine
de jours et ces propos qui sont
publiques et que vous pouvez trouver
dans la presse donc je sais pas qui a
révélé de secret et je n'étais pas
encore mis en examen ni placé sous le
statut de témoin assisté il ya quinze
jours pour les passeports
je vais vous accorder en effet sur le
mes déclarations et pour être encore
plus précis que vous l'êtes
lorsque j'ai répondu à madame la
sénatrice est à la fois sur les
passeports j'ai dit je pense je pense et
penser c'est une nuance qui a une
extrême importance que mes passeports
sont dans mon bureau à l'élysée et
qu'ils ont dû être restituée pensée
n'est pas affirmé mais tout ce que je
peux vous affirmer je les fais encore
une fois sous serment aujourd'hui c'est
que mes passeport était à l'elysée le 19
septembre
voilà monsieur le président sion il y a
eu ensuite une perquisition c'est la
dernière question de notre corps à
porter car nous avons beaucoup de
collègues qui demandent également la
parole
donc il y a eu une perquisition et
ensuite on vous a rendu les passeports
est ce que vous êtes plus vous pour être
plus précis quelle personne vous a rendu
les passeports au coin d'une rue
avez-vous dit c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé
encore une fois une information
judiciaire qui est ouverte et la justice
exposera dans des conditions claires la
manière dont les passeports ont été
rendues puis ensuite restituée comment
et par qui vous la même chose que
remportera madame jourdain juste une
question oui et après nous laissons la
parole à nos collègues de la commission
des lois
s'agissant des passeports de service
monsieur strzoda nous expliquer que vous
bénéficiez de deux passeports de service
l'un qui avait été délivré en 2016
lorsque vous travaillez à la délégation
interministérielle aux outre-mer et
l'autre délivré le 28 juin 2018 dans le
cadre de vos fonctions à l'elysée pour
si vous nous confirmer ces informations
c'est à dire la détention de ses deux
passeports pour bisous pouvez vous nous
expliquer quel en était l'utilité dans
la mesure où vous disposez déjà de deux
passeports diplomatiques
je suis encore désolé madame la
sénatrice je ne pourrais pas répondre à
cette question qui porte sur une
information judiciaire qui est en cours
adam jourdain vous voulez vous avez une
conception extrêmement large de
l'information monsieur bénard mais je
n'ai pas le pouvoir de vous faire parler
si vous ne le souhaitez pas je ne peux
que me rallier aux explications long qui
ôte aux données par le président bas et
déploré que vous ne souhaitiez pas
répondre à la mission d'information
juste je voudrais madame la l'accord
apporte monsieur benalla vous dire que
j'ai répondu de la manière la plus
précise complète et cohérente depuis le
début de vos auditions à l'ensemble de
vos questions je ne décide pas d'être
mis en examen ou placé sous le statut de
témoin assisté ou qu'une information
judiciaire soit ouverte ou non je
respecte juste le cadre de ce qui m'a
été conseillé par mon avocate de ne pas
faire d'autant incrimination ce que dès
lors que vous êtes mis en cause par la
justice et le statu quo porte peu celui
de mise en examen ou de témoin assisté
toutes les déclarations que je peux
faire devant vous sous serment peuvent
être retenues contre moi par la justice
ultérieurement donc
excusez moi juste de respecter des
principes qui me sont garantis par la
constitution
c'est bien là je suis d'accord avec vous
sur ce point
le risque de l'auto incrimination nous
ne voulons pas nous mêmes que vous
puissiez l'an courir mais quand il
s'agit du fonctionnement de
l'administration ce n'est pas des actes
que vous avez commis que nous vous
demandons de parler mais des actes qui
ont été accomplis par des services de
l'administration vous voyez vous sentez
bien la différence entre les deux et il
faut que vous cessiez de considérer que
les deux enquêtes parlementaires et
judiciaires devraient s'exclure l'une et
l'autre elles se complètent
elles ne sont pas en concurrence nous
sommes aussi très heureux que la justice
fasse son travail
elle fait un travail que nous ne
pourrions pas faire mais de la même
façon nous en faisons un qu'elle ne
pourrait pas faire non plus c'est pour
ça que dans d'autres républiques les
dispositifs de contrôle sont multiples à
chacun son rôle
voilà mais nous dira s'il vous plaît
nous allons nous en tenir là parce que
mes collègues vous vous reposer des
questions vous aurez l'occasion de
nouveau de vous exprimer juste monsieur
le prêt à leur allait juste excusez moi
simplement vous me posez des questions
sur l'administration
je les questions qui m'ont été posées
m'ont été posées à moins directement
concernant des actes que j'aurai
accompli ou de l'usaj que j'aurais pu
avoir ou l'utilité que j'aurais pu avoir
à me faire délivrer ces passeports
c'est là que c'est la nature même de la
question qui m'a été poussés parce que
là ça touche à votre à votre fonction à
l'elysée la question était pourquoi
auriez-vous encore besoin d'un nouveau
passeport diplomatique au mois de juin
alors qu'on nous a dit vous ne l'avez
pas démente et que vous étiez décharger
de votre participation à l'organisation
des déplacements du chef de l'état à
l'étranger
c'est juste ça et c'est vrai que je dis
que vous auriez normalement dû être en
mesure de répondre à cette question
sable sans vous exposer au risque d'auto
incrimination
je suis en situation de pouvoir déduire
de votre non réponse que la question
vous gêne
non pas du tout absolument pas et si
j'avais des questions qui me gênait je
vous l'aurais dit depuis longtemps
j'aurai pas répondu de manière aussi
claire est longue et précise que je les
fais depuis 19 septembre
ce que je peux vous dire si ça votre
question concerne le fonctionnement de
l'administration
ces passeports ont été délivrés
normalement et sans qu'à aucun moment
une objection quelconque interviennent
depuis que j'ai quitté mes fonctions
ou alors que j'étais en fonction c'est
tout ce que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui monsieur le président bas et
si l'administration avait jugé anormale
la délivrance des passeports
elle l'aurait souligné elle l'aurait
soulever pour les passeports de service
ils ont été annulés et pour les
passeports diplomatiques je constate que
non et le service du protocole de
l'elysée informé par le quai d'orsay du
renouvellement de ce passeport
diplomatique ne nous a fait aucune
observation
non je vous remercie monsieur watts blé
monsieur bel âne à ma question est la
suivante entre le 1er août date à
laquelle monsieur vous êtes licencié le
30 et le 31 décembre 2018
vous avez d'après monsieur strzoda
directeur du cabinet du président la
république utiliser deux passeports
diplomatiques une vingtaine de fois lors
de ses déplacements
avez vous comme l'avait indiqué dans la
comté de presse toujours prévenu la plus
haute autorité française
monsieur ben alla je suis même sûr sept
ans mais je ne commenterai pas les
articles de presse je commenterai mes
propres déclarations en l'occurrence un
communiqué qui a été le mien j'ai avisé
des personnes de l'ensemble de mes
déplacements à l'étranger
par courtoisie républicaine je n'ai pas
saisi la commission de déontologie de la
fonction publique mais j'ai expliqué un
peu ce que je faisais depuis que j'ai
quitté mes fonctions
ma question était plus précise la plus
haute autorité française
alors ce n'est pas une personne c'est
une institution dont je parle mais ces
bd là qui sont les personnes que vous
avez informé
donc les gens qui travaillaient à la
plus haute autorité française
c'est-à-dire des membres de la
présidence de la république et qu'elle
fonctionne occupe-t-elle je ne souhaite
pas évoquer leurs fonctions aujourd'hui
ni leur nom ni leur prénom je suis
désolé monsieur sueur à quelle date
avez-vous prévenu les personnes en
question de l'elysée de votre
déplacement au tchad alors je suis
désolé mais je ne répondrai pas à cette
question monsieur le rapporteur sur qui
concerne des déplacements postérieure à
mes fonctions à l'elysée
ça lui permet d'accélérer notre audition
président si vous le permettez je sais
ce qui se passe après ce qui se passe
après un rapport avec ce qui s'est passé
avant dans les déplacements que vous
avez fait récemment mais tout à fait le
droit de vous déplacer
yat il était question de la sphère
d'activité dont vous étiez chargé à
l'elysée y at il une connexion entre la
sphère d'activité dont vous étiez chargé
à des 10es est l'objet de ses
déplacements au n'y at il aucun rapport
il n'y a aucun rapport
et lorsque vous avez été reçu par des
chefs d'état est-ce que vous avez été
reçu par rapport à des missions
vous pourriez nous parler ou pas ou par
rapport à ce qu étaient vos anciennes
fonctions a aucune
j'ai été reçu en tant que alexandre ben
alors et je suis désolé mais je n'ai pas
pu changer de prénom
je pense que ni de nom et que
malheureusement
contre mon gré il a acquis une notoriété
qui est parti jusqu'en afrique les
schèmes été reçue pour remplir aucune
mission pour mon ancien employeur ni
même pour avoir des fonctions ou des
emplois ou des discussions en rapport
avec mes anciennes fonctions c'était des
déplacements à titre privé j'ai
rencontré un certain nombre de personnes
à titre privé et je les ai rencontrés
avec mon prénom est mon nom qui
s'appelle alexandre benalla voilà je
suis désolé de ça mais c'est le cadre de
ses déplacements
je suis con didier merci monsieur le
président monsieur benalla d'abord sa
propre peau liminaire il est exact
effectivement des manifestations
largement postérieures au 1er mai ont
montré des violences lors des
manifestations telles que j'en faisais
état mais c'est sur les passeports
toujours vous devez vous interroger sur
la pratique courante
est-ce que selon vous ces pratiques
courantes effectivement d'utiliser des
passeport diplomatique ou de service
jusqu'à expiration port parce qu'ils ont
quitté hull et les fonctions si c'était
interdit
vous vous l'at on dit déjà été dit
puisque aujourd'hui votre ancien
employeur a porté plainte pour ce motif
c'est la première question en étiez vous
informer
et quelle est la pratique courante selon
vous est-ce que vous soyez le seul est
poursuivi pour avoir violé cette
interdiction
la deuxième question c'est d'appel vous
dit avoir informé la présidence quand
vous refusez donner les noms sauf si
vous étiez en missions officielles ou
parallèles pour le la dgse ou que sais
je vois pas en quoi vous pouvez ne pas
dire à la commission denquête qui vous
avait informé mais nous avons entendu le
ministre de l'intérieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères le directeur de
cabinet nous dire qu'ils ignoraient tout
de vos déplacements à l'étranger pendant
quatre mois ne l'avoir découvert que par
le canard enchaîné alors est ce que ça
vous paraît vraisemblable vous même bon
marianne vos sites en disant que vous
aurais dit comme ça ils sauront suis bon
à voir ce que ça vaut mais est-ce que
très honnêtement il pouvait l'ignorer
de la même façon à ce que vous paraît
vraisemblable
que l'ambassadeur de france à djamena
n'est pas informée paris de ce que vous
vous soyez déplacés au tchad vous
paraît-il vraisemblable que mills
affaires étrangères nous disent avoir
tout appris
le 26 sachant que le président de
république a été là le 22 décembre à
paris enfin dernière question d'autres
oliviera djamena n'djamena par mail et
par ailleurs troisième question vous
disiez vous même avoir gêné dans vos
fonctions et est là n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment d'avoir gêné certains nous
disent que vous n'existez plus à
l'élysée que vous êtes mort d'autres
disent au contrat que vous auriez pu
renseigner même utilement le président
sur l'emploi des forces de l'ordre
pendant les manifestations ou encore sur
la réalité au tchad y compris sur le
rôle des russes pourquoi pas au tchad et
et qui était nécessaire pour le
président de le savoir et qui n'auraient
pas par les voies officielles
et est ce que vous n'avez pas à ce
moment-là irrité irrité est ce ce que ce
serait pas à l'origine je dire de la
plainte et des ennuis homme qui vous
sont faits et des informations qui nous
sont donnés merci ve ment aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup chers collègues alors une
pile poil vous tenez votre tanger
admiratif et est donc monsieur benalla
pouvez-vous répondre à l'ensemble de ces
questions alors sur l'information que je
ne pouvais pas utiliser ces passeports
elle ne m'a pas été fournies par aucun
moyen que ce soit ce que je vous ai dit
en propos liminaire et je leur confirme
encore devant vous ils m'ont été rendue
début octobre et ils étaient utilisables
c'est à dire sans aucune mention ne sut
pas accompagnée d'un courrier qui
m'empêchait de les utiliser
et c'est une connerie de ma part de les
avoir utilisés au vu de la polémique et
qui est sorti après ils sont été rendu
par qui je vous ai déjà dit que je ne
répondrai pas à cette question de
secours du bédat adore la présidence de
la république qui nous a menti
je pense que l' enquête judiciaire va
déterminer la vérité avec les moyens qui
sont les siens
mais je vous affirme sans porter aucune
accusation que j'ai rendu mes passeport
à la fin août et qui m'ont été restitués
on début octobre
en ce qui concerne la pratique courante
j'ai entendu à l'occasion de vos
auditions que une inspection générale
avait été diligentée par le ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères et
qui s'étaient aperçus qu'un certain
nombre de passeports diplomatiques alors
même que les personnes ne cesser leurs
fonctions
continuez en tout cas si ce n'est pas de
les utiliser à les conserver
je suis incapable de vous dire si des
gens se servent de leur passeport après
je vous répète juste le propos qui a été
celui d'une des personnes que vous avez
auditionné
c'est à dire que des gens quittent dans
plusieurs administrations d'ailleurs et
qui dispose de passeports diplomatiques
quittent leurs fonctions et ne restitue
pas les passeports en question est-ce
qu'ils voyagent avec je suis incapable
de vous y répondre moi en tout cas j'ai
avoué de la manière la plus simple
possible que j'avais voyagé avec ses
passeports et j'en assumerai les
responsabilités ma responsabilité devant
la justice qui aujourd'hui me le
reproche
et voilà c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire là dessus sur les autres sur les
autres questions est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être là j'ai pas noté la troisième
question qui était la vôtre monsieur
grosdidier
est ce que le miz affaires étrangères
pouvaient ignorer
je veux dire aux déplacements le
ministre d'intérieur est ce que
l'ambassadeur de france pouvait oublier
de signer les à paris que vous étiez à
la djamena de 12 alors que le président
il y aller le 22 et est il vraisemblable
que le musée affaires étrangères ne le
découvre que le 26 je n'en sais rien je
suis pas dans la tête du ministre des
affaires étrangères simplement j'ai
d'une brève dans le canard enchaîné qui
expliquait que la direction de la
coopération internationale qui est un
service qui dépend du ministère de
l'intérieur avait été informé de
certains de mes déplacements à
l'étranger
voilà et qu'il n'avait pas fait remonter
l'information
moi en tout cas je peux vous affirmer
j'ai informé des personnes qui devaient
en connaître par courtoisie encore une
fois la présidence je les fais en mon
nom propre en ma responsabilité
concernant les autres acteurs se soient
des ministres ou des responsables
d'administrations je ne sais pas quels
ont été leurs démarches ou pas est la
dernière question par les informations
que vous pouviez avoir ou donner ce que
vous n'aviez pas indisposer la sphère
administrative ou technocratique
je vous remercie de me donner cette
chance de pouvoir expliquer de manière
publique est très claire et sous serment
je ne détient aucun secret aucun secret
sur qui que ce soit je ne fais aucun
chantage
on essaye d'expliquer un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements de la part de
l'état un certain nombre de négligences
et d'erreurs et de fautes de ma part que
je reconnais devant vous que je reconnus
devant la justice et j'assume mes
responsabilités mais il faut pas en
déduire que tout ça au final est due à
un secret ou des secrets que je
détiendrait je ne détient aucun secret
j'avais une fonction clair que je vous
ai exposé au 19 septembre
j'ai rempli ma mission de manière claire
et je ne suis pas parti avec des secrets
sur qui que ce soit et j'essaye juste de
reprendre une vie normale et de me
refaire par moi-même sans demander
l'aide de personne voilà monsieur
sénateurs ce que je voulais vous dire
merci monsieur benalla madame benbassa
merci pour les détenteurs de passeport
diplomatique ou de service
une note verbale du ministère des
affaires étrangères est demandée pour
l'obtention du visa d'entrée sur le sol
tchadien
j'ai le document ici je précise que
cette formalité est demandé dans le cas
de court séjour comme de longs séjours
ma question est simple messieurs benalla
aviez-vous à disposition cette note
verbale pour entrer sur le sol tchadien
comment avez vous pu produire un tel
document est ce que le quai d'orsay vous
à
livrer une telle note pour obtenir le
visa
si vous n'aviez pas ce document
expliquez-nous pas quels moyens
vous avez pu obtenir votre visa alors je
vous délivre ce document si vous voulez
le voir
et deuxièmement je voudrais savoir si
c'est possible qui vous arrive situer
les passeports en octobre et
troisièmement vous avait révélé dans la
presse avoir eu des contacts avec le
président de la république jusqu'au 24
décembre un télégramme vous vos échanges
était-il privé ou d'une nature plus
officielle et daniel question votre
épouse était salariée de la raim haut
débit des affaires vous concernant
pouvez vous nous dire quels étaient ses
fonctions est elle toujours salarié de
la reine avez vous vous même encore des
contacts ou des fonctions avec le parti
présidentiel merci donc c'est ben ben
ali merci mais c'est un triste pour vos
questions je n'ai pas connaissance de
cette note verbale
je suis rentré au tchad 2 oui mais je
n'ai pas connaissance de cette note
verbale
je suis rentré au tchad sans visa
simplement avec un tampon et une
délégation économique étrangère ce que
j'avais déjà précisé donc ben j'écoute
et je suis rentré au tchad de sang tout
faudra peut-être poser la question à
d'autres autorités mais moi je ne sais
pas je n'ai pas fait de demande de visa
pour aller au tchad sur votre deuxième
question excusez moi j'ai par deuxième
question c'est
vos contacts la teneur de vos contacts
avec la présidence lors de vos échanges
par un télégramme
est-ce qu'ils étaient privés ou d'une
nature plus officielle je ne commente
pas les articles de presse encore une
fois tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que je n'ai plus de contact avec qui que
ce soit à la présidence de la république
ou au parti de la république en marche
depuis le 24 décembre et la question sur
votre épouse qui était salariée de la
règle est elle toujours
je pense que ma femme n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec toute cette histoire a
donc je ne parlerai pas de ma famille si
je vous remercie
ce que je peux avoir le document
monsieur pilet si monsieur le président
j'ai gagné là si je vous avais posé la
question que je pensais pouvoir vous
poser dès le départ je crains que vous
ne me répondiez que vous ne pouviez pas
il répondra raison de la procédure
pénale
aussi je vais
modifier le caractère de celle ci je
voulais vous poser la question de savoir
si quelles étaient les raisons pour que
vous ayez sollicité en tout cas pour
qu'on vous ait attribué quatre
passeports en même temps mais je vais
l'extraire totalement dugas benalla et
vous poser la question suivante est-ce
qu'il est habituel que pour des
personnes remplissant les missions
telles que vous allez dis les remplir et
style habituel d'avoir quatre passeports
en même temps à quoi ça sert de bena la
concernant bon c'est pas 4 passeport on
sait toutefois pas ce port
le premier passeport de service et ayant
été attribués en 2016 dans le cadre
d'autres fonctions et dont la
restitution n'a jamais été demandé non
plus à cette occasion il est habituel je
pense que les affaires étrangères vous
avez répondu c'est clairement sur le
fait de détenir deux passeports
diplomatiques pour des raisons de
demande de visa c'est juste fonctionnel
en ce qui concerne le le passeport de
service je vous le répète excusez moi de
le répéter de gelée obtenu dans des
conditions d'obtention normale et pour
des raisons normale et il ya je voudrais
pas être affirmatif sur la chose mais il
ya des gens qui détiennent plus de
passeport diplomatique que j'ai plein de
détenir et c'est quelque chose de normal
partir du moment où vous demander à
l'administration un certain nombre de
documents
c'est assez fluide les les contacts les
contacts entre les administrations sont
assez fluide si j'avais fait une demande
qui aurait paru bizarre où ib le
ministre de l'intérieur n'aurait pas
délivrer le passeport en question voilà
merci madame lherbier mais monsieur le
président monsieur benalla quand vous
déplaciez là lors des vingt déplacements
vous étiez seul où vous étiez en
délégation est une autre question me
vient à l'esprit les fonctionnaires lors
des passages aux frontières temps à
l'entrée qu'à la sortie ne vous ont posé
aucune question ne vous ont pas n'ont
pas été surpris de quoi que ce soit
vis-à-vis de votre vos passeports chez
ben à la merci pour votre question
madame la sénatrice gens comme toi je
vais répondre à une question que je ne
suis pas obligé de répondre parce que ça
concerne mais des déplacements privés à
l'issue de mes fonctions je me suis
déplacé des fois seuls des fois en
délégation je peux pas vous donner les
détails exacts de ces déplacements et
mais passeport qui ont été utilisés à
une vingtaine de reprises 23 fois
exactement pour être tout à fait exact
l'ont été pour justifier simplement de
mon identité au passage frontière ne
m'ont fait bénéficier donc un avantage
si ce n'est à deux reprises du fast
track au lieu d'avoir la carte premium
je suis passer plus rapidement et donc
les autres fois à une dizaine de fois je
me suis déplacé dans un avion privé donc
avec les avantages que cela procure mais
sans jamais facilité quelque chose je me
suis soumis à l'ensemble des contrôles à
lors de ses déplacements sur le
passeport diplomatique ne vous immunise
absolument pas je suis passé aux
portiques de sécurité
mes bagages on est passé au sont passés
aux rayons x fois la fin tout à fait
tout à fait je vous remercie
je donne la parole à madame un monsieur
dur merci monsieur le président monsieur
bd l'ats le porte parole du gouvernement
a évoqué des dysfonctionnements à
l'elysée ces dysfonctionnements sont au
coeur de notre
travailler parlementaires ils
constituent ils se constituent par des
faits les conditions d'attribution de
restitution de non restitution de larmes
de service des passeports du téléphone
théorème ils sont aussi constitués par
le la compréhension des mécanismes et
des circuits décisionnels à l'elysée les
interactions entre les différents
protagonistes de l'organisation
élyséenne nous avons appris que vous
auriez demandé au directeur de cabinet
de l'élysée de réécrire votre lettre de
démission
est ce que c'est vrai et est-ce que par
ailleurs il vous est arrivé assez
fréquemment de d'imposer ainsi vous vu à
monsieur strzoda et une seule question
si je comprends bien monsieur le
sénateur en ce qui concerne la lettre de
licenciement alors des jeux pour vous
informer d'où elle sort dans la presse
et c'est une pièce de la procédure
judiciaire en cours concernant l'effet
du 1er mai c'est une exploitation de mon
téléphone portable dans lequel il ya un
sms qui est envoyé à monsieur strzoda où
je lui dis que la lettre qu'il a écrite
n'est pas la vérité est que je signe la
réalité des choses je n'ai pas imposé
mais vu j'ai juste exercer un droit qui
est le droit à la vérité et la lettre de
licenciement la première mouture qui
avait été écrit par monsieur strzoda
indiqué que personne n'était au courant
que j'étais parti en stage d'observation
à la préfecture de police le 1er mai ce
qui malheureusement n'était pas la
réalité
donc j'assume mes responsabilités et je
les assume
quand la réalité est écrite
si on écrit un mensonge je le dénonce et
je veux juste vous faire constater que
le courrier a été modifié et qu'il a
suivie la réalité des faits c'est à dire
que mes autorités étaient au courant que
j'allais le 1er mai en tant qu
observateur sur la manifestation
je vous remercie madame mercier
merci monsieur le président monsieur
benalla vous avez déclaré dans la presse
que vous étiez resté en lien avec le
président de la république jusqu'au 24
décembre
vous avez dit que la teneur de vos
échanges étaient sur des faits sociétaux
comment vous voyez les choses les filets
jaunes etc
cela se serait passé par sms en nous
avons compris que le téléphone théorème
le téléphone crypté avait été désactivé
le 4 octobre
donc est ce que cela veut dire que vos
échanges ont eu lieu avec un téléphone
que je qualifierais de base donc le
président de la république utilise un
téléphone commun je vous remercie madame
la sénatrice pour votre question j'ai eu
un certain nombre d'échangés avec un
certain nombre de personnes sur des
messagerie crypté je pense que c'est un
fait qui est sorti dans la presse depuis
le début du mandat
et depuis le début de la campagne je
n'ai jamais eu des changes avec le
théorème depuis le 1er juillet avec qui
que ce soit merci de cette réponse
monsieur le président caennais benalla
je voudrais revenir sur les déclarations
de monsieur le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères le
16 janvier dernier
monsieur le ministre on nous disait que
le 26 juillet à 2018 une demande
officielle de restitution de vos pass
pâte matic
vous avez été adressées et que l'accusé
réception avait bien été retiré le 10
septembre puisque manifestement vous
n'aviez pas obtempéré une nouvelle
lettre vous parvenez et celle ci n'était
pas retiré entre temps le 1er août vous
avez été licencié et vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure que pendant quelques
jours si j'ai bien compris vous aviez
utilisé vos passeports diplomatiques
pour cette mission privée dont vous ne
voulez pas évoquer le contenu
ma question est simple ils auraient une
deuxième tout à l'heure comment vos
passeports sont ils revenus à l'elysée
puis
les 19 septembre vous affirmiez que ces
passeports était à l'elysée et permettez
moi de vous dire que semblerait que vos
combos était plus nette que ce que vous
avez déclaré tout à l'heure première
question
deuxième question plus factuel
connaissez-vous un personnage qui
s'appelle philippe ababou seulement
monsieur benalla excusez moi
concernant votre question elle concerne
la restitution du passeport c'est bien
samedi c'est d'être que vous avez
utilisé pendant quelques jours mois
d'août
si j'ai bien compris du 1er au 7 août
point tout est neuf c'est tout et donc
ils sont repartis à l'elysée commence
quand il repartit est ce que vous êtes
passé l'elysée monsieur strzoda nous
ayons dit que vous n'y avait pas mis les
pieds à l'elysée à compter du 1er août
les propos de monsieur strzoda sont pas
tout à fait exacts mais sans rentrer
dans des précisions qui encore une fois
concerne l'information judiciaire en
cours j'ai fait redéposer un certain
nombre d'effets personnels dont mais
passeport diplomatique à un personnel
salarié de l'elysée courant du mois
d'août plutôt vers la fin août
d'ailleurs voilà c'est pour la première
question
la deuxième question je connais monsieur
philippe hab la boule sur le monde tout
à fait et je les connu après mes
fonctions au mois de octobre 2018 pour
être tout à fait exact
je sais kerrouche merci monsieur le
président monsieur b dallas une question
toute simple
vous nous dites que vous avez récupéré
les passeports début les passeports
diplomatiques début octobre
question vraiment simple pourquoi les
acceptez vous alors que manifestement il
était en lien avec des fonctions que
vous n'exercez plus ça c'est la première
question la deuxième mais je crains que
vous ne souhaitez vous ne souhaitiez pas
y répondre
puisque vous êtes dans le cadre d'une
enquête préliminaire sur faux et usage
de faux
ce qui ne vient pas contrevenir
l'activité de la commission denquête
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
déclaration de monsieur strzoda sur la
fabrique d'infos de votre part pour
demander un passeport de service au
ministère de l'intérieur
ce la preuve
oui non sur la restitution des
passeports c'est l'erreur que j'ai
reconnue et que je reconnais encore une
fois devant vous je pense que moralement
il aurait été plus prudent de les
laisser dans le sac plastique
ça n'a pas été fait c'est une bêtise je
les assume à 100 % en ce qui concerne
votre deuxième question le seul constat
que je fais c'est que n'ait pas été mis
en examen sur les qualifications de faux
et d'usagé de faux
je n'ai pas d'autres déclarations à
faire concernant les propos de monsieur
strzoda je vous remercie de cette
réponse monsieur marc merci président
monsieur benalla il apparaît que lorsque
vous avez intégré le cabinet de la
présidence de la république
vous n'avez pas fait de déclaration à la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique
vous auriez dû le faire puisque les
textes en la matière nous avons bien
regardé ils sont très claires y at il
quelqu'un qui à l'elysée vous a dit que
vous auriez dû faire et cette
déclaration à laquelle nous sommes
astreints nous les parlementaires ou
toutes personnes gravitant par exemple
au tour de l'exécutif ou des exécutifs
aujourd'hui vous allez faire une
déclaration à la commission de
déontologie et ce six mois après que
vous ayez quitter vos fonctions divisée
à quel moment et qui vous a demandé ou à
exiger de vous que vous fassiez cette
déclaration est pourquoi avoir mis
autant de temps à la rédiger un merci
monsieur sénateurs pour votre question
en ce qui concerne la déclaration
préalable d'entrer à l'elysée à la haute
autorité pour la transparence dans la
vie publique
la sphère la pseudo-affaire benalla a
révélé le fait que les chargés de
mission n'y ont jamais été astreint et
ce n'était une pratique courante depuis
un certain nombre de quinquennats et que
dès lors que
il ya eu cette affaire le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république
demandé aux neuf autres chargés de
mission de remplir cette déclaration je
tiens à vous informer que indices eu de
mes fonctions de septembre j'ai rempli
une déclaration de fin de fonction à la
haute autorité pour la transparence dans
la vie publique et en ce qui concerne la
commission de déontologie pour la
fonction publique
j'ai pris connaissance de cette
obligation encore une fois trois jours
avant l'audition de monsieur patrick
strzoda devant vous qui m'a envoyé un
courrier dont je pourrais que je
pourrais vous fournir
éventuellement si vous en avez besoin où
il m'indiquait que c'était très
important de saisir cette commission est
malheureusement je n'ai pas relu mon
contrat de travail à l'issue de mes
fonctions j'en suis absolument désolé
c'est encore une erreur de ma part
il est vrai que ce courrier aurait
certainement pu vous être adressées plus
tôt par exemple au mois de juillet ce
qui ne vous dispersez pas d'exécuter vos
obligations
madame eustache brinio monsieur ménard
j'ai bien noté dans le début de mon
propos que vous confirmiez que vous
aviez laissé vos passeports à l'elysée
vous refuser de répondre à la question
qui vous les a rendus et comment ils
vous ont été restitués ça j'ai bien noté
cela aussi moi une question que kim qui
m'interpelle vous avez été licencié le
24 août avec 24 juillet pendant avec un
effet au 1er août
on est d'accord pourquoi vous avez
continué à utiliser des passeports
diplomatiques pourquoi comme tous les
citoyens de ce pays
vous n'avez pas utilisé un passeport
ordinaire comme moi j'en ai un pour
faire vos déplacements à quel niveau
avez vous estimez que votre passeport
diplomatique était nécessaire pour vous
déplacer
on peut se déplacer avec un passeport
ordinaire on passe les frontières
peut-être avec un peu plus de temps mais
on n'est pas ce dont qu'est ce qui
justifiait que vous avez absolument
voulu utiliser des passeports
diplomatiques pour ses déplacements et
c'est toujours très très simple devait
n'y a aucune nécessité de l'utilisation
de ces passeports et je le répète encore
une fois c'était une bêtise une erreur
de ma part et ça ne m'a pas facilité la
vie plus que ça au passage contrôle
frontière j'ai échappé à aucun contrôle
ce soit à contrôler l'identité bagages
c'est voilà peut-être une erreur de ma
part monsieur le comte
oui merci monsieur le vrai monsieur
bénard vous faire préciser quels lots
les changes que vous avez que notre
collègue madame benbassa sur votre
entrée au tchad 3 questions
la première est ce que vous êtes rentré
au tchad avec votre passeport
diplomatique sans visa comme vous ne
l'avez dit ou est-ce que vous avez
présenté au aux autorités tchadiennes un
passeport qui n'était pas diplomatique
deuxième question est ce que vous avez
est ce qu'il ya eu des demandes de visa
sur votre passeport diplomatique
depuis le 1er août une troisième
question est ce que vous êtes et ce que
vous avez voyagé avec votre passeport
diplomatique dans des pays où un
passeport diplomatique contrairement à
un passeport ordinaire est exempté de
demande de visa la première réponse je
suis rentré au tchad avec ce passeport
diplomatique
je n'ai jamais fait de demande de visa
avec ce passeport diplomatique
mais ce ne l'est pas fait madame et on
m'a acceptée au tchad
donc je ferai demandé de poser la
question aux autorités tchadiennes
savoir pourquoi ils m'ont laissé rentrer
mais en tout cas je n'ai pas été refoulé
à la frontière et en ce qui concerne le
voyage dans des pays qui exempte le
passeport diplomatique de bizarre je ne
vais pas faire pas ma connaissance
monsieur benalla la sortie de france
personnes dans les services de la police
de l'air et des frontières ou à la
douane ne s'est opposé à l'utilisation
de votre passeport diplomatique à aucun
moment monsieur le président bat donc
vous l'avez utilisées pour sortir
il m'est arrivé de l'utiliser je vous
remercie
monsieur loïc hervé monsieur le
président monsieur vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure à voir restituer un pin's
est ce celui du gspr par ailleurs
collaborateur du président de la
république
vous bénéficiez d'une habilitation
secret défense au terme d'une enquête
menée par le sgdsn
quand avez-vous rempli et signé le
formulaire de demande combien de fois
quand et par qui
avez vous été auditionné pour obtenir
votre accréditation de secret défense et
enfin le début et la fin de votre
accréditation secret défense ou doses
ont ils été notifiés si oui quand alors
subhanallah en ce qui concerne le pin's
j'ai entendu aussi beaucoup de choses et
lu beaucoup de choses dans la presse en
aucun cas le pin's qui est porté par les
membres du cabinet de la présidence de
la république n'est similaire à celui du
gspr le pin's du j'espère est un pin's
noir avec les armoiries de la présidence
et 3 étoiles qui signifie c'est
l'acronyme de la protection rapprochée
le ping qui est délivré aux membres du
cabinet et ainsi qu'à certaines
personnes des services administratifs
comme les photographes les intendants
qui met ce pin cela pour être identifier
plus facilement lors des déplacements du
président de la république est un pin's
rompt avec les couleurs bleu blanc rouge
et la mention présidence de la
république dessus il est numéroté et il
est attribué nominativement par le
commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée sur instruction du directeur de
cabinet
en ce qui concerne l' enquête
d'habilitation elle n'a pas été
effectuée par le sgdsn le gds n
effectuent les enquêtes simplement pour
les habilitations très secret défense ce
dont je n'étais pas habilités j'ai été
habilités par mon autorité d'emploi
c'est-à-dire le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république sur rapport
de la dgs et la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure dont je pense que
les enquêtes sont assez poussées et dont
je ne connais pas la nature
c'est par essence le but quand on
procède à des enquêtes de ce type là en
ce qui concerne la notification d'une
feinte d'habilitation l'habilitation
étant donné dès lors que vous occuper
des fonctions à la fin de vos fonctions
lé cas du elle devient caduque
et c'est le cas dans l'administration
quand quelqu'un est sur un poste qui
nécessite une habilitation secret
défense et qu'il quitte ce poste pour
prendre une nouvelle fonction il n'est
plus habilité comme il l'était avant
l'habilitation dépend du poste que vous
occupez monsieur hervé veut compléter sa
que vous voulez dire que vous n'avez à
aucun moment été auditionné entendu en
vue d'une habilitation secret défense au
démarrage de votre choix de l'elysée
alors sans trahir de secret en ce qui
concerne les habitations ce que moi même
je n'en suis pas détenteurs la seule
fois où intervient une audition dans le
cadre d'une habilitation s'est dès lors
qu'il ya un problème dès lors qu'il y a
un problème qui est soulevée par les
services ils viennent ils vous demandent
de répondre à une convocation qu'elle
vous devez déferré et répondre à un
certain nombre de questions qu'ils se
posent sur des failles susceptibles de
vous un pacte est donc n'ayant pas été
auditionné par ses services c'est qu'il
n'y avait aucune raison de douter
ou en tout cas de mme auditionné sur des
faits qui auraient été portées à leur
connaissance
l'am3 engley merci monsieur le président
monsieur ben ali vous nous avez dit le
tout à l'heure quand on a la question
était posée sur le téléphone théorème
que vous aviez le souci du respect des
procédures
ma question porte sur la le moment où
vous avez récupéré vaut au passeport
diplomatique
vous nous avez dit que pour vos
déplacements il vous arrive est
d'informer des personnes très haut
placées à l'elysée de vos déplacements
est-ce que c'était lié à une procédure
et je m'en explique
est ce qu'on vous a demandé est ce que
quelqu'un vous a demandé de tenir
informé de vos déplacements
sinon qu'est-ce qui a pu vous motiver
qu'est-ce qui a pu expliquer votre
démarche auprès de ces personnes
sinon que le président de la république
en soient informés je vais jusqu'au bout
de ma question peut-être ce n'est pas du
tout votre démarche
et est-ce que vous avez infirmer ces
personnes lorsque vous êtes allés au
tchad
tu venais là non
pour répondre à votre question j'avais
aucune obligation d'informer la
présidence de la république de mes
déplacements je les fais par courtoisie
et paradoxalement je les fais pour
éviter ce qu'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui
et l'erreur de ma part de l'utilisation
des passeports n'a pas aidé en soi à
l'idée c'était que quand je me déplace
connaissant la notoriété qu'a provoqué
un peu cette affaire qu' il n'y ait
aucune interprétation du à ses
déplacements en l'occurrence je n'avais
pas été informé du déplacement presse du
président de la république trois
semaines après le mien au tchad et
[Musique]
l'elysée a été informé de ce déplacement
au tchad
postérieurement à ce que je l'effectué
cergy je suis allé au tchad et je les ai
informés que j'avais été au chat je les
ai pas informé avant d'y aller c'est ce
qu'a provoqué ensuite toute cette
histoire
voilà mais je n'avais aucune obligation
à le faire je les fais par courtoisie
voilà madame traîne les voulait rebondir
vous l'avez fait par courtoisie pour que
le président de la république en soit
informé monsieur ménard
non je les fais surtout pour que les
services soient informés et que
l'entourage du président de la
république le soit également de manière
à ce qu' il n'y ait pas de conclusion
est qu'on soit un minimum au courant de
ce que je faisais a déçu de mon
licenciement
monsieur fichiers oui merci monsieur le
président tu as voulu revenir simplement
quelques instants sur l'histoire du
téléphone théorème on nous est expliqué
ici qu'il y avait quatre mille 600
appareils
en fonctionnement à l'échelon national
une trentaine qui était au niveau de
l'elysée et que l'utilisation de ce
téléphone nécessité que le correspondant
est le même téléphone
donc on est sur quelque chose qui est
extrêmement cadré extrêmement précis et
je voudrais savoir si vous avez eu
l'utilisation fréquente de ce type de
téléphone est le cas c'est chiant avec
quel type de correspondants et comment
vous expliquer qu'un téléphone aussi
important aussi rare cryptée puis cet
égard et pendant plusieurs semaines
voire mois et que vous le retrouviez par
hasard dans vos cartons
alors que vous ne paraissez par ailleurs
si soucieux d'être professionnel et de
bien utiliser le matériel de le rendre
en temps voulu c'est vrai que c'est
quand même un outil très précieux et
rare alors c'est un coup de finale
alors c'est un jeu c'est un outil comme
vous l'avez dit qui a coûté très cher à
l'état et qui est très peu utilisé
malheureusement alors qu'il était à la
disposition de toutes les personnes qui
en ont besoin moi je me déplaçais
j'organisais des déplacements j'étais en
lien avec des autorités préfectorales
des autorités de police et donc j'en
avais une utilité et c'était avec ces
personnes là que j'ai changé en ce qui
concerne le pourquoi il appelle je n'ai
pas retrouvé par hasard j'ai retrouvé
parce qu'après avoir reçu le courrier du
directeur de cabinet et je voulais être
sûr et certain que je n'avais plus roulé
en ma possession appartenant à la
présidence de la république
donc je les retrouver par des recherches
de manière à pouvoir le rendre de
manière spontanée ce qui a été fait par
mon avocate
j'explique pas le fait qu' il se soit
rendu compte que ce téléphone n'était
plus à le mois d'octobre en tout cas moi
je n'ai jamais été informé ni sollicitée
par quiconque pour le restituer je les
fais de ma propre initiative
comme je lé fais pour les passeports
diplomatiques après l'éclatement du
scandale et via mon avocate
voilà ce que je peux vous dire monsieur
le sénateur merci monsieur bénin
monsieur françois noël buffet merci
monsieur le président et ce benalla vous
êtes licencié le 1er août 2018
vous bénéficiez de passeports
diplomatiques de service qui vous
donnent naturellement qu'ils sont liés à
votre fonction pendant la période du 1er
août au 31 décembre
vous voyagez 20 fois à 20 reprises 23
fois précisément vous avez dit tout à
l'heure voyager à titre personnel pour
mener des missions personnel ne vous
considère d'ailleurs qu'elle ne regarde
pas la commission ce qu'on peut partager
naturellement on vous demande le
gouvernement en tous les cas vous
demande à deux reprises à partir du mois
d'octobre de restituer ces passeports
les lettres qui vous seront envoyées ne
seront pas retirés
vous ètes semble-t-il soucieux de la
régularité des choses vous l'avait redit
trouvez vous normal cette situation de
voyager à titre personnel avec des
passeports qui était lié à la fonction
que vous n'occupez plus est ce que ça
vous paraît normal que beynat
alors juste pour repréciser monsieur le
sénateur ce que je pense que vous êtes
garé au niveau des dates
j'ai reçu les correspondances du
ministère des affaires étrangères à la
fin du mois de juillet 2018 plus un mail
du général bio farina qui me demandait
de restituer un certain nombre
d'affaires
j'ai restituer ses affaires dans le
courant du mois d'août 2018 et quand ces
passeports ont été rendus début octobre
je n'ai après plus jamais reçu de
relance de la part du ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères on
m'a rendu ces passeports en l'état
utilisable sans aucune interdiction de
les utiliser si ce n'est un cadre que je
qualifierais de morale et dont j'assume
la responsabilité aujourd'hui certes
c'était une bêtise de les utiliser donc
ce n'est pas normal et vous avez raison
de le souligner monsieur le sénateur ce
n'était pas normal d'utiliser ces
passeports
je les fait et j'en assume la
responsabilité devant vous et devant la
justice également merci de votre réponse
vous souvenez peut-être également sans
doute l'avez vous appris que le 10
septembre 2018 la cheffe du bureau
compétents du ministère des affaires
étrangères vous avez écrit un deuxième
courrier par lettre recommandée avec
accusé de réception
réception vous demandant de restituer
ses deux passeports et d'après ce qu'on
nous a dit ce courrier n'a pas été
retirée par vous même vous n'avez pas
trouvé la foi
j'en ai pas pris connaissance il n'a pas
été retirée et c'était encore une
période un peu compliquée pour tout vous
dire voilà je vous remercie madame di
folco merci monsieur le président
monsieur benalla monsieur castaner
ministre de l'intérieur nous a dit lors
de son audition le 16 janvier que vous
aviez fait une demande directement au
quai d'orsay pour obtenir un passeport
de service il vous aurait été refusée
parce que cette demande doit émaner de
l'employeur vous auriez donc alors
produit un document rédigé par vous même
sur un papier à en-tête du chef de
cabinet document non signé donc s lusage
de faire un faux documents pour arriver
à ses fins pourquoi avez vous besoin
vraiment de ce passeport de service fin
juin 2018 alors que vaut une mission
avait été considérablement réaménagé et
donc a priori plus besoin de vous
déplacer avec le président de la
république à l'étranger et je me
permettra aussi de vous demander si vous
avez produit un faux document à ce
moment là on avez-vous produits d'autres
à d'autres moments durant vos missions
sur une assist mais je reconnais que je
crois pas que monsieur benalla puisse
nous répondre sur le fait qu'il aurait
ou non produit des faux documents pour
le coup j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure
quelle était l'étendue de notre mission
à monsieur bénin à lui même
je comprends votre préoccupation et
d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas la seule à
l'avoir mais ce sont des questions
susceptibles d'être tranchée par la
justice
même si comme monsieur benallal a relevé
s'agissant de son passeport de service
il n'a pas été mis en examen de ce chef
là quant à son passeport diplomatique
il n'a jamais été allégué qu'il aurait
commis un faux du moins
je l'ignorais les rapporteurs
aussi il a juste été souligné que ce
passeport diplomatique lui a été
renouvelée suite à une demande qu'il a
fait lui même est alors que normalement
c'est le service du protocole qui fait
les demandes de renouvellement des
passeports diplomatiques des
collaborateurs du président de la
république sur un saut jez et ça n'a pas
été le cas
mais monsieur benalla et qui lui a une
conception extensive de duchamp de ce
qui relèverait exclusivement de la
justice n'a pas voulu nous répondre sur
ce point alors même qu'aucun soupçon ne
pèse sur lui à cet égard en revanche sur
les passeports de service
un soupçon pèse sur lui puisque le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république a déclenché la procédure de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
sur ce sujet pour lequel monsieur
benalla n'est à ce jour pas mis en
examen
donc monsieur mais la lave alors vous
pouvez répondre merci mme chan en
question dans la mesure où vous le
souhaitez
juste pour rebondir sur votre propos est
pour répondre partiellement en tout cas
la question qui m'a été posée tout à
l'heure ce n'est pas le service du
protocole qui prend la décision de
octroyés ou passeport diplomatique
ils ont juste les demandes démarches
administratives sur instruction du
cabinet du président de la république
évidemment voilà voilà mais il est exact
aussi que ce renouvellement n'a pas été
demandée à travers le service du
protocole cette fois ci il a été
suffisamment considérer pour pouvoir
donner lieu à une délivrance
normal oui c'est ce qu'a pensé le
ministère des affaires étrangères
exactement nous avait informé le service
du protocole tout à fait qu'il n'a pas
vu à les revoir
quant à la témoin mais vous même je
n'avais pas eu l'idée que
il n'y avait pas de justification compte
tenu de l'évolution de vos fonctions à
une demande de passeport diplomatique je
vous dis justement que j'ai répondu
partiellement à votre question monsieur
le président bah j'en suis désolé mais
j'ai répondu partiellement à votre
question c'est ce que ce n'est pas le
service du protocole qui prend la
décision d'octroyer ou de délivrer un
passeport diplomatique
ils ont un rôle de transmetteur entre la
présidence de république et le quai
d'orsay
et ça n'est pas de web dont il a
transmis la demande de renouvellement
exactement très bien il l'a reçue juste
seule information que le passeport avait
été renouvelé
oui voilà vous même vous avez fait votre
demande directement au quai d'orsay
c'est pas exactement comme ça que ça
s'est passé comment ça se passe et je le
dirai la juge d'instruction mais
peut-être qu'elle ne vous le demandera
pas tandis que moi je vous le demande
la question m'a déjà été posée en garde
à vue pour tout vous dire oui et c'est
pas une raison pour ne pas répondre mais
je veux c'est être partie de
l'information je reconnais je reconnais
que je reviens sur un aspect de nos
échanges pour vous donner une ultime
chance je comprends je précise et c'est
je le fais en réalité avec bienveillance
monsieur dallo j'imagine bien et c'est
pour ça que je préférais répondre à la
justice devant lequel il ya d autres
choisissent et à qui vous vous référez
répondre tout à fait c'est bien je vous
en donne acte je ne peux pas faire
autrement dans le cadre des textes et
dans le cadre des textes suivis nahla je
suis tout de même obligé de vous
rappeler les dispositions
la personne qui refuse de déposer devant
une commission denquête est passible de
deux ans d'emprisonnement et de 7500
euros damende notre les auront à
délibérer bien sûr de la manière dont
vous nous avez répondu ou plutôt de la
manière dont vous ne nous avez pas
répondu à des questions dont je vous
redis que j'estime qu'elle relève de
notre commission denquête même si la
question pouvez vous est posée par
exemple d'une information judiciaire
tout à fait oui mais le juge
d'instruction vous apposez certainement
aussi beaucoup d'autres questions sur
des faits pour lesquels vous répondez à
nos questions car
les faits qui sont qui font l'objet de
la justice sont abordés sous un angle
différent mais ce sont en partie les
mêmes faits que ceux sur lequel nous
mettons en oeuvre nos investigations
c'est donc bien normal qu'un juge
d'instruction vous pose des questions
dans un domaine pour lequel il n'estime
pas devoir engager des poursuites et que
nous posions aussi des questions sur ces
faits mais j'ai dit j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de vous expliquer ça je suis
persévérant et vous vous êtes d'obstiné
et si bien que nous n'arrivons pas à
déboucher sur une réponse qui paraît
très satisfaisant j'aime la commission
donc je comprends bien monsieur le
président votre souci j'ai juste un seul
souci c'est celui de la présomption
d'innocence et de la john genre de la
note aux incriminations et à partir du
moment où vous auto incriminer donc à
partir du moment où je vous parle sous
serment
il ya des choses que je ne peux pas vous
dire mais il ya des noms se sont pas des
propos mensongers contrairement à ce que
vous dites madame l'accord à porter il
n'ya pas mais tout vient de là c'est mon
droit
c'est mon droit et il faut juste le
respecter partir du moment où une
information judiciaire est ouverte
contre vous quel que soit votre statut
il ya des choses que vous pouvez dire
d'autre que vous ne pouvez pas dire et
je suis assez soucieux me sylla sur
linde 20 sur trois sachets le seul
endroit que la manière dont ces débats
ont eu lieu tout à fait est bien entendu
simplement je vous dis qu'il ya des
questions auxquelles je ne peux pas vous
répondre et que je réserve sérémé
réponse à la justice j'en suis désolé je
fais un choix qui est celui qui aimait
conseillé par mes avocats
prenez tous puissent y ont aussi
interprété dans nos réponses bien
entendu david de nos prérogatives
constitutionnelles entendu et nous
interroger sur les raisons profondes de
cette mort est bien entendu excusez moi
madame qu'il faut que vous devez
compléter cette question merci monsieur
le président moi aussi je suis un peu
insistante mais si vous ne pouvez pas
répondre à l'ensemble de mes questions
peut-être quand même pourriez vous
répondre en partie pourquoi aviez vous
besoin le 28 juin 2018 d'un passeport de
service alors qu'on t'a passeport
diplomatique le vin le passeport de
service
ah non pardon le 28 juin c'est vous qui
avez raison d'un passeport de service
j'ai raison parce que j'ai pris des
notes d'un passeport de service alors
que vos fonctions avait été modifié
pourquoi aviez vous besoin d'un
passeport de service le 28 juin au point
d'en faire une demande
même hors cadre juste madame la
sénatrice je soulève que votre question
de tout à l'heure parce quand même la
question de la présomption d'innocence
et je vous fais remarquer juste je vous
fais je vous fais remarquer juste après
que le président ballet fait également
que je n'ai pas été mis en examen sur
les faux et usage de faux
alors attendez je vais essayer de donc
l'émeute urbaine et là je reprends
aviez-vous encore pour l'exercice de
fonctions réellement besoin d'un
passeport de service le 28 juin dernier
si la question vous est posée nous
laissons totalement de côté le point de
savoir si vous avez demandé ce passeport
de service au moyen de ce que le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république a qualifié de faux ou pas
nous laissons de côté cette question
intégralement nous vous demandons si les
gars à la fonction que vous exerciez
alors il était justifié de disposer d'un
passeport de service
je vais vous faire la même réponse parce
que ça fait trois fois que vous me posez
la question il ya une information
judiciaire qui est en cours
j'ai reçu ce passeport de la manière la
plus normale du monde
et c'est monsieur là c'est curieux tout
de même que vous vous abritez derrière
la mission de la justice
en vérité quand ça vous arrange mais
vous avez fait tout à l'heure un long
dégagement sur les actes qui vous sont
reprochés le 1er mai pour les justifier
alors là vous parlez d'une question que
nous ne vous avons même pas posée qui
relève intégralement de la justice et
vous ne vous privez pas de porter une
appréciation sur le rôle que vous avez
eue et sur la justification de ce rôle
au regard d'un article du code pénal que
vous nous avez rappelé là pour le coup
la justice elle a beau être saisie vous
êtes tout à fait à l'aise pour entrer
dans des détails que nous vous ne nous
vous demandons pas et quand nous vous
posons des questions qui ont trait à
votre mission à l'elysée et aux raisons
pour lesquelles vous pourriez avoir un
passeport de service
alors là vous vous abritez derrière une
information judiciaire alors même que
comme je les dis comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous n'êtes pas mise en examen
malgré l'article 40 qui a été utilisé
par le directeur de cabinet du président
de la république donc véritablement il
ya dans la manière dont vous utilisez le
travail de la justice des contradictions
de semble-t-il comme vous l'avez
souligné qui a été révélé par l'article
40 qui fort opportunément a été rendu
public devant votre commission même
moment où le chef de cabinet était en
train de déposer devant les policiers à
la veille d'une garde à vue qui vous a
été annoncé donc ça aussi je pense qu'il
faudrait le soulever maintenant je pense
que j'ai le droit à une défense que
j'allais être entendu dans les toutes
prochaines heures donc c'est à peu près
c'était à peu près compréhensible en été
entre les fils et madame la sénatrice et
que aujourd'hui je pense que personne
ici n'est dans ma situation et donc j'ai
eu droit à une défense
j'ai le droit de ne pas moto incriminés
vous avez le droit de me poser beaucoup
de questions et moi je vous donne les
réponses
donc comme je l'entends
c'est ce que c'est ce que nous
constatons donc vous mettez en oeuvre
votre stratégie de défense devant la
commission d' enquête du sénat qui elle
ne s'intéresse nullement à ceux dont la
justice est saisie
je vous remercie monsieur bigot merci
monsieur le président une question fort
simple monsieur bédard à savoir si vous
êtes en possession d'un passeport
ordinaire comme tous les français
peuvent en avoir et si oui pourquoi ne
l'avez vous pas fait le visage j'ai
compris que vous disiez c'est une bêtise
d'avoir utilisé par 23 fois le passeport
diplomatique
c'est toujours là une fois que l'on met
poursuivi qu'on se dit on a fait une
bêtise aurait mieux fait de le faire
mais les passeports ne servent pas qu'à
passer les frontières
lorsqu'on est dans un pays et que l'on
veut comme vous l'avez fait rencontrer
des autorités il ose souvent utile
d'avoir aussi un passeport
je pense que pour accéder à la
présidence de la république d'un état
quelconque qui vous demandent quand même
des papiers sans doute que le passeport
diplomatique facilite de ce point de vue
là les contacts donc si vous aviez un
passeport ordinaire
pourquoi avez-vous fait usage de
passeports diplomatiques de questions
qui a déjà été posée mais à laquelle
vous pourriez apporter une réponse plus
précise peut-être alors j'ai un
passeport normal et d'ailleurs il a été
utilisé entre le 7 août et début octobre
2018 parce que je n'étais plus en
possession des passeports diplomatiques
ça c'est la première réponse à votre
première question la deuxième réponse
c'est que j'ai fait une erreur je le
répète pour la sixième fois et que quand
vous êtes dans visite dans un pays
étranger
vous ne vous présentez pas devant le
bâtiment de la présidence de la
république en exhibant votre passeport
fort haut et clair pour dire je veux
être reçu par le président regardez j'ai
un passeport diplomatique
ça ne fonctionne pas tout à fait comme
ça vous vous présentez un contrôle
frontières pour justifier de votre
identité vous attestez de votre identité
et ensuite vous rendez vous avez les
rendez-vous qui ont déjà été convenu à
l'avance vous en voyez pas non plus
mail avec la photocopie du passeport que
vous détenez encore pour obtenir ce type
de rendez vous c'est pas exactement
comme ça que ça fonctionne je vous
remercie madame marie b merci monsieur
le président je vais essayer de revenir
de manière un peu plus générique et aux
questions qui vous ont été posées
auxquelles vous ne voulez pas répondre
vous avez répondu tout à l'heure à
monsieur pilet que les passeports
avaient été délivrés normalement par
l'administration
donc nous pouvons en déduire qu'il était
normal en tant que responsable de
sécurité
que vous ayez trois passeports
diplomatiques et deux passeports de
service d'une manière générique en
faisant abstraction de votre cas et de
la procédure en cours
pouvez-vous au regard de ce qu'était vos
fonctions expliqué les utilisations
respectives de ces deux types de
passeports services et diplomatiques et
les raisons et les procédures par
lesquelles ils ont été attribués une
deuxième question dans l'inventaire qui
vous a été demandé pour la demande de
remise des faits liés à votre fonction
sur la procédure de restitution de ces
pièces dans l'inventaire des pièces qui
faisont été demandé est-ce qu'il
figurait est-ce que figurait le
téléphone
le téléphone crypté sur benalla merci
madame la sénatrice pour votre question
je pense qu'elle a déjà été posée donc
je dans le même cadre je n'y répondrai
pas je n'étais pas responsable de la
sécurité je tiens vous soulevez je
croyais avoir fait un exposé assez
précis lors de ma première audition
j'avais un statut de chargés de mission
et des fonctions d'adjoint au chef de
cabinet du président de la république ce
qui n'est pas exactement la même chose
que responsable de la sécurité aux
gardes du corps comme je l'entends
encore régulièrement en ce qui concerne
la question de la restitution des effets
personnels
je tiens à préciser que le théorème
n'était pas inscrit sur le courrier de
patrick strzoda à mon intention bien que
non membre de notre commission monsieur
cédric perrin souhaite poser une
question je lui donne donc la parole
monsieur perrin merci monsieur le
président une très rapidement juste pour
exercer un point vous avez expliqué
avoir eu non pas quatre mais trois
passeports diplomatiques si c'est bien
ce que j'ai entendu et vous avez une
fois de plus et vous expliquer que
certains n'étaient plus valables parce
que enfin vous ne savez pas utiliser
parce qu'il n'était plus valable a
priori lorsque vous auriez pu vous vous
déplacez avec ma question est simple
est-ce que ces passeports diplomatiques
vous avez pu en avoir pris possession
avant d'entrer à la république en marche
et avant d'entrer à l'elysée
monsieur ben alla alors pour répondre à
votre question
j'ai eu était en possession de quatre
passeports de passeports diplomatiques
de passeports de service trois
passeports mais ont été octroyés pendant
ma présence à la présidence de la
république pour être précis et je n'ai
jamais eu de passeport diplomatique
avant mes fonctions à l'elysée
monsieur jean pierre sueur si monsieur
le président
quelques questions très courte en
complément la première est très simple
monsieur benalla vous êtes vous rendu à
l'elysée depuis que vous avez été
licencié
je ne répondrai pas à cette question sur
le co-rapporteur étant donné que ça
s'applique peut-être ou pas après avoir
quitté mes fonctions
oui mais
alors monsieur sur veut savoir en
réalité si je ne me trompe pas si vous
avez poursuivi une forme de
collaboration avec la présidence de la
république après votre licenciement afin
de vérifier que ce licenciement a été
pleinement suivies d'effet je crois que
c'est le sens de la question de notre
reporter non ça dépend si on entend la
présidence de la république en tant que
bâtiment ou la présidence de la
république en tant qu'institution je ne
me suis jamais j'ai jamais eu de
collaboration professionnelle avec
l'elysée postérieure à mon licenciement
concernant la première concernant la
première réponse devront alors vous vous
ne dont vous ne répondez pas mais vous
fait un distinguo entre le bâtiment et
l'institution si je vous comprends bien
tout eu
mais si vous voulez j'insiste sur le
fait que ce qui s'est passé après votre
départ fait partie strictement de nos
prérogatives pourquoi parce que vous
avez vous deviez et vous allez sans
doute faire une déclaration auprès de la
commission de déontologie
puisque dans les mois qui suivent une
haute fonction comme celle que vous avez
exercé
naturellement il est très important dans
l'intérêt de l'état qu'il ne soit pas
fait usage d'aucune façon de la fonction
précédente
au bénéfice d'une fonction suivante
c'est pourquoi après avoir pris note de
votre réponse il nous a été dit que vous
n'étiez pas venu vous ne dites pas que
vous n'êtes pas venu mais on ne sait pas
si vous êtes venu dans le bâtiment dans
l'institution peut-être dans
l'institution bien je voulais vous
parler encore une fois parce que voyez
vous nous aimons je vais dire ça
gentiment vous nous aimons les belles
histoires vous c'est tout le monde lit
des romans des histoires bon mais quand
même nous sommes sous serment
vous menez une activité et je comprends
tout à fait que vous ayez de souci de
mener une activité vous rencontrer
monsieur solomons et il vous trouve
sympathique je suppose
vous vous retrouvez après en voyage avec
lui et nous savons que ce voyage est un
voyage économique d'ailleurs vous nous
l'avez dit et il n'y a rien de
répréhensible en fait qu'il y ait des
relations économiques bien sûr et des
organismes qui s'en occupe et des
entreprises qui s'en occupent mais quand
même vous êtes là vous allez voir un
deux trois quatre je ne sais pas moi je
me demande pas chef d'état c'est quand
même pas anodin
après avoir été licencié de l'elysée
vous êtes dans des délégations et vous
êtes à titre personnel quand vous êtes
là parce que c'est votre liberté d'être
là et vous êtes devant monsieur le
président du tchad et d'après ce que
nous avons compris mais peut-être ai-je
mal compris monsieur solomons s'occupe
de vendre paraît-il des uniformes et
vêtements militaires mais j'ai lu ça
comme vous dites dans la presse et je
sais que vous n'êtes de d'accord départ
beaucoup de crédit à ce genre de
déclarations
mais vous avez à participer à cet
entretien là aussi vous pouvez ne pas
répondre mais est ce que vraiment lors
de cet entretien il n'aurait été
question que de cette activité marchande
est ce que vous êtes sûr que dans vos
déplacements
il n'a jamais été question d'aucune des
fonctions que vous avez exercé que vous
n'avez jamais été reçus en référence aux
fonctions vous avez exercé ou au motif
que vous pouviez jusqu'au 24 décembre
communiquer en particulier avec les
disait est ce que vous êtes sûr qu'il
n'y a aucun aspect dans les
conversations économiques qui sont
encore légitime qui auraient trait à des
questions liées à la défense ou à la
sécurité
est-ce que vous pouvez vous engager
devant nous sur ces questions sous
serment
c'est bien à la merci monsieur le
rapporteur pour votre question
première remarque j'ai envie de tout
faire je ne vois pas le rapport entre le
licenciement et l'impossibilité d'être
reçu par un chef d'état étranger qui est
souverain et qui fait absolument ce
qu'il veut s'il a envie de me recevoir
s'il a envie de m'inviter à venir le
voir je vous en donne et s'il y avait
tout à fait raison sur le plan du droit
je vous remercie
et s'il a envie d'avoir une discussion
est toutefois sauf si la commission de
déontologie n'a pas été saisis pour
s'assurer que nouvelle activité était
conforme aux règles déontologiques qui
sauf que la commission de déontologie je
ne pense pas qu'elle ait le pouvoir de
m'interdire de rencontrer des gens de
voyager et d'essayer de faire quelque
chose de ma vie et non pas de mettre
enfermée chez moi en fin fond de la
normandie en touchant les allocations
emploi de pôle emploi
donc j'ai servi bien d'une collaboration
salariés qui non non j'ai eu une
collaboration à partir du mois de
novembre
le salaire gelé perçu d'une société qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle france clause
protection qui m'assaillent pendant un
mois et à vous parler de vous parler des
déplacements c'était à titre privé je
veux juste être très précis va avec
monsieur président bah je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion du déplacement avec monsieur
philippe ababou sur le monde perçu une
rémunération spécifiquement pour ce
voyage spécifiquement pour ce voyage au
tchad
donc je n'ai pas été emmené au tchad
contre rétribution pour faciliter
quelques quelconque la sphère que ce
soit contrairement à ce qui peut être
sous-entendu vous êtes rétribués par qui
et pourquoi
je pense que ça ne vous concerne pas
aujourd'hui monsieur le cours à 10
heures ça me concerne je m'excuse mais à
partir du moment où l'on est dans les
six mois qui suivent l'exercice d'une
fonction importante
la loi prévoit une obligation de saisir
la commission de déontologie pour parler
des activités et que la commission
statue sur le fait qu'il n'y a aucun
rapport entre les activités que vous
exercez présentement et les missions qui
étaient les vôtres
il y a quelques mois au sein de la plus
haute institution de l'état
alors ne vous énervez pas michèle
conchon
pas énervé je suis plein de conviction
vous le savez bien tout le monde le sait
d'ailleurs parfait je vous dise ça
regarde ça regarde peut-être la
commission de déontologie qui va être
saisi par mon avocat
mais je n'ai pas à vous dire aujourd'hui
ce que je fais de quoi je vis où je vis
avec qui et comment je me déplace à ces
questions nous on vous sait très subtil
équilibre des cas si votre employeur et
pour quelle activité dans quels domaines
nous avons le droit de le demander
puisqu'il ya un droit de suite par
rapport à ce que vous faisiez à l'elysée
et d'ailleurs je vais vous dire quelque
chose ça c'est pas couverts par la
justice et d'autre part se serait très
bien que vous répondiez parce que dans
ce cas nous aurions l'assurance qu'il y
à votre réponse nous donnerait
l'assurance qu'il n'y a aucun rapport
entre ce que vous faites présentement si
vous occuper d'un autre domaine
d'activité
on dira très bien bonne chance et
réussissait mais le fait que vous ne
répondiez pas engendre forcément le
soupçon et nous nous disons mais comment
pouvons nous être sûrs que ces voyages
que ces contacts n'est pas un rapport ni
avec ce que vous avez fait avant ni avec
les contacts que vous avez encore eu
jusqu'au jour de noël avec la présidence
de la république
alors monsieur v n'a encore une fois je
pense que ça rentre dans le périmètre de
l'instruction ce que j'ai pu faire comme
déplacement à quel titre et avec les
passeports diplomatiques et que deux je
pense que ma vie d'aujourd'hui me
concerne moi et seulement moi et que je
fais tout dans le respect des lois
depuis que j'ai rendu les passeports
diplomatiques ma vie privée et ma vie
professionnelle et je ne vais pas
répondre de manière perpétuelle à toutes
les questions qui me sont posées par les
journalistes dix fois par jour savoir
qui je rencontre qui je vois ce que je
fais de qui je suis salarié je pense que
ça ça me regarde moi monsieur benalla
les questions qui vous sont posées ici
ne sont pas les questions des
journalistes et le statut de vos
réponses n'est pas le même que celui des
réponses que vous donnez quand vous
consentez vous même des interviews dans
la presse
nous allons nous en tenir là et je vais
vous demander de bien vouloir vous
retirer ainsi que votre conseil et nous
allons poursuivre nos travaux
c'était l'audition d'alexandre benalla
devant la commission d' enquête du sénat
une seconde audition centré sur ces
passeports diplomatiques qu'il a
utilisée après son départ de l'elysée
l'ancien chargé de mission a voulu
démontrer qu'il n'avait pas menti lors
de sa première audition devant les
sénateurs
il a expliqué qu'il avait bien rendu ces
passeports diplomatiques aux services de
l'elysée au cours du mois d'août mais
qu'un salarié de la présidence de la
république lui avait restitué en octobre
en lui précisant que ces passeports
étaient bien utilisable
alexandre benalla a aussi indiqué qu'il
avait informé certains membres de
l'elysée de ses voyages à l'étranger et
notamment au tchad
trois semaines avant la visite des
manuels macron vous l'avez vu les
échanges avec les sénateurs ont été très
tendues lorsqu'alexandre benalla a
refusé de répondre à certaines questions
sur cette affaire en invoquant l'
enquête judiciaire en cours
mais les sénateurs nous ont rappelé
qu'ils étaient obligés de répondre à ces
questions car elle concerne le
fonctionnement de l'état objet de l'
enquête du sénat la commission des lois
décidera si elle engage ou non des
poursuites contre alexandre benalla
c'est la fin de cette émission pour voir
tous nos programmes sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]